there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on it's
Wednesday big main show May show the
show that we've done already this is the
third Zodiac Killer show we've done I
thought that it sounded familiar because
the original I went back and checked the
original zodiac show that we did was way
back on episode 109.
and then I remembered that we talked
about that Gary post guy like when that
happened and I thought that we had done
it like just as maybe like a News
segment like at the beginning of a show
like about a different topic but when I
was like looking back through our [ __ ] I
realized that we also we did a Zodiac
Killer Revisited show less than a year
ago it was actually uh in December of
2021 and it was episode
278 and that was the one that we talked
about Gary post on now interestingly
though
um
when I was like researching the show
this time it kind of seems like man
there's a new Zodiac Killer [ __ ]
suspect every five minutes and it's just
like just this morning uh I came up with
two new ones one of them doesn't sound
all that compelling like it's kind of
there's a couple like circumstantial
things but the second guy
that that might that might be onto
something they might be onto something
with that but you know I know they say
that about everybody but I don't know
we'll get into that because I find that
I found that like really interesting and
I only just heard of the guy this
morning it's like he wasn't even a dude
that came up on any of the suspect lists
or anything like that so
very it was I I found it very compelling
but like I said I've been wrong before
obviously
I thought the new ice maker was showing
up today it's not showing up until
tomorrow it will be red this one we went
on about red ice makers yeah and today
we are drinking a [ __ ] wonderful
drink
it's key lime pie that's what I'm gonna
call it it's
um Pinnacle Whipped cream vodka
and homemade lemonade yeah [ __ ] it's
good it is very good it's like a dessert
yeah yeah it tastes just like key lime
pie yeah you can taste the whipped cream
in it and everything yeah it's really
nice the only thing missing is the
graham cracker crust
what are we good oh we should put graham
crackers like crunch up some graham
crackers and put them around the rim
yeah that's right you salt the rim of
graham crackers yeah that would be
really good do we have it do we have any
graham crackers yeah there might be a
graham cracker um imagine Pinnacle
probably makes one called graham cracker
just probably that you can mix with that
yeah
they make everything that's okay yeah
they've made like every conceivable
flavor over the years well it's like
anything you know any flavors that you
know work well in a dessert like you
know they're gonna make vodkas like
flavored that so you can mix them
together and make but that is actually
like really good it's [ __ ] real good
you could probably put lemon vodka in
that too if you want to like make it
stronger yeah
I think it's just good with whipped
cream vodka and lemonade it does taste
just like key lime it tastes just like
but like I said now you're making me
want oh you know what we could do is
maybe kind of like a compromise do we
still have some of that cookie butter
we could like put some oh no it's not a
cookie butter we put some of the cookie
butter on the rim because that's like
not it's not graham cracker but it's
similar like it's kind of that similar
cookie but it's not sweet yeah it was
like we ate that [ __ ] up who sent us
that Tammy I forgot yeah somebody came
in about a while back yeah it was a
bunch of stuff I think it was I think it
might have been Tammy yeah you put them
on [ __ ] buttered toast and then put
man that should be delicious put cookie
butter in there I mean it was good to
just eat like off a spoon seriously just
that right out of the jar but I liked it
on buttered toast yeah yeah it was real
good yeah
Dave's in the house good evening you two
you're making me thirsty yeah well you
know yeah get a drink get a drink it's
Wednesday night we're gonna talk about
uh zodiac again
that's zodiac part three well see I'm
kind of wondering now that I found that
out I'm like well should I cover the
whole case again
uh no we have time I mean I guess so I
mean if I guess if we get into a into a
spot where we're just kind of like we
can go back Running Out of Time parts of
it yeah then because I do definitely
want to get into the new guy like well
the two new guys but mainly the one new
guy but you know like the new [ __ ]
that's happened because one of the I
don't know if you know this but the um
that uh what's it called the z340 cipher
that's been solved uh yeah yeah I heard
about that noise yeah it got solved it
didn't say anything exciting but um but
yeah it did get solved so you know we're
gonna talk about that too how come they
couldn't solve it before did they ever
um computer solve it I'm not really sure
no people saw it was like three guys uh
that solved it but um I mean you know it
took I don't know why it took so long it
wasn't anything new really he was just
just more rambling no he was just like
rambling about the same [ __ ] that he
always rambled about like you know that
you'll never catch me that kind of stuff
yeah like [ __ ] like that so he was just
kind of like doing that to yank
everybody's chain
dick like that
um let me see hold on one of these days
you should review the film The Usual
Suspects I'm amazed that we haven't done
that already actually I think I did put
it in the poll a couple times but I
don't think it ever won
and let's see I'm gonna just kind of
already say but uh since you're doing a
discussion on the Zodiac Killer one of
these days you should review the film
Dirty Harry because the villain Scorpio
was inspired by the Zodiac Killer yeah
I've seen that one yeah I know we
haven't done the first uh dirty area yet
have we
uh also Camp guy said the whole thing
reminds me of David Berkowitz Sloan
gunman walk him to cars and shooting the
couple inside yeah we did a show about
David work yeah I thought we did a long
time ago yeah we I think we've done like
most of the big heavy I don't think we
have to go over this case everybody
knows this case we gotta just kind of I
mean if we talk we'll just kind of do it
naturalistically you know what I'm
talking about talk about the new ones
and we might be able to refer back to
part parts of the case if we have to but
I don't think we should go over the
whole case it'll take a long time
well I don't know like I could maybe
give because I have all the notes and I
just I'm I'm afraid that if we just talk
about the new [ __ ] then the show's gonna
only gonna be like 20 minutes long you
know so I don't know I don't know what I
want to do because I do kind of feel
like
yeah people know the details of it but
maybe some people don't you know what I
mean I was like I was watching a video
earlier like about it and there was a
comment in there from somebody that was
Australian and they said and they were
young and they didn't know anything
about the Zodiac all right well if we
could do this so if we do the Zodiac
case it's gonna have to be kind of a
fast a kind of a fast uh fast and loose
version of it because [ __ ] that could
be four hours right there
talking about the Zodiac [ __ ] kids
that you got two hours
yeah yeah well I mean this is main show
so we usually like to do like kind of a
longer main show okay but you know what
I'm saying I just don't want it to be I
just don't want it to be too short is
what I'm saying because if we just talk
about things you get an hour and a half
out of it
oh I don't know maybe
I'm not real sure like I said I didn't
really like think that much about this
because I just assumed that we were
gonna like go over the case again
and then talk about the news we'll let
the audience decide because when I did
when I prepared for the show I didn't
realize until like literally 10 minutes
before the show started that we already
did a Zodiac Killer Revisited less than
a year ago yeah I didn't realize well
yeah that's the thing but I don't
remember y'all don't remember it
that's true it's like well yeah it's
like we've done so many shows because
you have to think like where this right
here is episode of the main Show episode
322 and that doesn't count all of the
movie reviews we've done all the other
live streams we've done all the haunting
shows we've done all the [ __ ] we talked
about doing and never did all the [ __ ]
we talked about doing in everyday yeah
um you know and the thing about it too
is that uh you know and then I started a
couple channels where I do like book
reviews and movie reviews so it's like
sometimes I get a little confused
um understandably so about what we've
covered and what we haven't and
particularly with True Crime cases
um I think I've brought this up before
like I've written about so many True
Crime cases like in my books and stuff
that sometimes I forget like did we do a
show about that or did I just write
about it right you know what I mean like
in my book because I'll be like
researching I'm like man this like
sounds really familiar but then I can't
remember like if we did a show on it or
if it just sounds familiar because we
did a book on it so the fact that this
is just hilarious to me that like
literally 10 minutes before the show I
was like oh [ __ ] we already did a zodiac
Revisited show like before I think that
happened before like didn't that happen
a couple months ago where I had put a
topic in the poll and it won and then
like I was getting ready to do the show
and then I realized that we'd already
done a show on that like not that long
ago and I was like well [ __ ] and then I
had to like change the topic at the last
minute because like I'm like we just did
a show about that like a couple months
back because and that's another thing
too is that I have to keep coming up
with
um new topics like to put in the polls
and sometimes you know I have this big
long list and sometimes like when we do
a show I would normally take it off the
list but sometimes I forget to do that
so sometimes it'll get put back into the
rotation because I forgot to take it off
the list and I forgot we did a show
about it so you know I have a lot going
on so sometimes like I'm amazed actually
sometimes that I keep track of [ __ ] as
well as I do but I you know I I do keep
like lose track of [ __ ] all the time so
I didn't even realize that we had done
a show uh in December of 2021 about
zodiac but that makes sense because
the whole Gary Francis post thing uh
that came out like in October of 2021
and then we ended up like doing a show
like mostly I think we went over the
case but then we talked about that guy
specifically but like the more that I
read about that guy I don't really think
that and for sure like law enforcement
are like they don't think that's the
dude either to me it just doesn't it
seems kind of
I don't know it just doesn't seem that
compelling to me but the guy that I read
about today
sounds a lot more like along the lines
of somebody that it would be you know
what I mean yeah which we'll get into it
in a minute then and I literally had not
heard of the guy before today Hugo's
liking my shirt yeah Omega Man original
design Jenny laid it out I'd do it
twenty dollars plus shipping depending
on what size you know unless it's an
extra extra large shirt you can drop a
super chat if anybody wants an Omega Man
shirt I'll make you one
bootleg as [ __ ] you can't buy that
anywhere else well yeah I made that blue
egg as [ __ ] I you know what I did I took
a screenshot yeah of the opening
title thing of the movie and then I
pasted it in illustrator and then like I
found a font that was similar uh which
is kind of like the Haunted Mansion font
like from Disney it's kind of the same
font as that and then I just like
adjusted it like an illustrator to look
exactly like that so I laid it over the
picture
um let's see
oh Samantha said Jenny do what you want
a bridge version is fine uh Hugo said I
wouldn't mind a bit of background okay
yeah I kind of feel like if it's better
to kind of like talk about the case
because you know if people forget
details I know a lot of people know
about the Zodiac Killer but like I said
there might be people that are younger
or people that are not from the US or
something like that that would
appreciate because I don't want to just
like jump into talking about being like
Oh in this case in that case and they
don't know what I'm talking about you
know what I mean
um and then Samantha said it's tough to
get old it is it it really is I've like
I said I used to have a mind like a
steel trap and like now it's kind of
still like a steel trap but now it's
kind of like a little bit like that like
some stuff like leaks out never down
then and I just like forgets him but
like I said in my defense I keep track
of a lot of things like you know what I
mean I do a lot of videos a week I do a
lot of writing I do a lot of other stuff
so I'm actually kind of amazed I'm
giving myself had on the back yeah it's
like I'm amazed that I don't know how
she does that I keep track of like well
now I have to write [ __ ] down and I have
a big I have a big calendar
and I have to write everything down on
the calendar so I don't forget like what
I'm doing from day to day but you know
so I do write [ __ ] down and like cross
it off when it's done because otherwise
I would forget [ __ ] you know what I mean
yep uh Isabella said I think you could
go through it and just figure out how
much detail to go through on the fly
yeah that's probably that's probably
what we'll do I mean
you know I'm just kind of
I don't know I guess like the more we
Yap about it like the longer it's gonna
take like before you get into this [ __ ]
but and it's [ __ ] I'm kind of loopy
if if I'm if if I'm acting an ass or
[ __ ] acting stupid uh on this on this
episode because I am dumb I'm normally
but man I haven't really been getting
any sleep I have [ __ ] yeah he's he's
been having to play I'm [ __ ] up I'm
not [ __ ] up yeah I've been I'm towards
the end of a [ __ ]
what in the fitness scene was called a
trend cycle and I'm and Trent do not do
Trend all right he's telling you right
now go do Trent uh he's not he's not
having a fun time no [ __ ] no I'm not
gonna do this one again and and by the
transitive property I am also not having
a fun time
well it's no no oh no we're it's nowhere
near as bad as it no I know I'm just
teasing I'm mostly just kind of stay
hidden yeah I'm just seizing you you've
been like yeah mostly he just like stays
in the in the room and like I stay in
the office it's
miserable [ __ ] most of the [ __ ] that
I take is [ __ ] like liquid sunshine
you just [ __ ] love it you know you
feel great real positive this [ __ ] here
man it spikes your [ __ ] estrogen
levels they [ __ ] fall to the [ __ ]
into the bottom your test levels are
[ __ ] real high and then all of a
sudden you get flooded with progesterone
and men aren't supposed to have a bunch
of [ __ ] progesterone in them
it makes you emo as [ __ ] and you start
thinking that [ __ ] people don't like
you and that everybody's cheating on you
and that they're lying so you got to
stay hidden
and and you're like a living Morrissey
album you [ __ ] emo I thought he said
the other day yeah your emo as [ __ ] man
and and like you're thinking about [ __ ]
that happened 30 40 years ago like that
[ __ ] broke my heart [ __ ] just all
kinds of weird [ __ ] man you get [ __ ]
real emotional so you gotta [ __ ] stay
hidden and then you you try to sleep
it's called transomnia try to sleep you
never fall asleep because you're just
[ __ ] jacked you're just [ __ ] wired
and you and then when you do sleep
because you're hyper vigilant kind of
like [ __ ] weird like hyper masculine
you never reach REM sleep yeah it's just
real shallow real shallow so you don't
like feel rested or anything and [ __ ]
I'm everybody says man you look great
[ __ ] you know I mean I look [ __ ]
huge I got my scale going because you
don't look at the scale you know I mean
I got my skill going God on there I lost
10 pounds
people were saying in the comment
section boy you look younger that's why
actually I Recon recomped I got I built
more muscle but I lost a lot of fat
uh but I I thought I'd I thought I was
reaching 200 pounds now I'm only 176
pounds and before I started this I was
in the high 180s
High yeah high 180s so I lost weight
weird I didn't expect that I thought
it'd be about 200 pounds
Zach said so basically Tom is
experiencing the last decade of my life
yeah you're gay man gay yeah [ __ ]
well Trend makes you gay I told him the
other day
and me and and me and Jen were talking
about this too I said dude you wouldn't
last a couple days as a one yeah because
that's I'm like so [ __ ] up I'm like so
how I've been my entire life yeah
I only got about a week of it left and
and really it's like the last few weeks
that everybody complains about because
it's all built up in your system it's
highly effective it burns a lot of fat
off you builds a lot of muscle
you feel like you're a God the first
couple weeks but then it just like I'm
not doing this [ __ ] again
the only good thing about it is that
it's very cost effective very cost
effective it's cheap
and it does a lot of [ __ ] quickly
like it would have taken 10 months and
about a thousand dollars worth of other
stuff to get where what it did to me had
I used something else but it's just too
damn aggressive no more Camp guy said do
an angels of death show plenty of those
dudes around doctors nurses and
orderlies that kill their patients we
did do an angels of death show I think
we covered four different killers on
there but I can't for the life of me
remember who they were I think we did a
couple of doctors and a couple of nurses
that had killed a bunch of people I'd
have to look back to see which specific
ones we did but I specifically remember
doing a show about that uh Camp guy also
said I saw something on YouTube the
other day about the new zodiac suspect
but I didn't look at it yet that yeah
that's what I came across today because
I was just kind of like looking you know
I kind of like read a bunch of Articles
and then like I look on YouTube and see
if there's anything new that's been like
put up about it and the two that I saw
were the most recent were actually two
different suspects one of them like I
said I'm not real sure how I feel about
it but the other one I was just kind of
like because I heard the guy talking
about it I'm like holy [ __ ] that sounds
like amazing and he had like a link in
the in the description box and I went to
that and it's like this big huge long
interview like an article I was like oh
my God I think this dude might be like
on into something although like I said
it's hard to say because
there's a bajillion [ __ ] zodiac
suspects and it seems like there's
always like a new one but I don't know I
kind of feel like this one maybe I don't
know maybe this is it's got to be
somebody right
I mean you know one of those people has
to be him
so why not you know I just don't have a
suspect
yeah maybe they don't have a dude I
don't know well this guy that he was
talking about had has never been named
as a suspect he was never uh
investigated as a suspect or anything
like I don't think he was ever even
arrested for anything as far as I could
determine so you know what I mean the
guy the guy that found him just kind of
found him by accident like when he was
researching some other [ __ ] which I'll
get into later on but yeah it was like
it was kind of like an interesting story
Danny Rowling said Arthur Lee Allen
looks nothing like any of the drawings
yeah and it's funny because I kind of
feel like and maybe a lot of people had
the same experience when you see the
David Fincher movie Zodiac which is an
amazing movie
but it's based on Robert graysmith's
book you know he was the you know he
worked for the San Francisco Examiner he
worked for one of the San Francisco
papers he was like a cartoonist and he
got like really really interested in the
Zodiac case and he was like and then he
wrote a book about it later on thank you
camp guy I'm interested in the shirt
wanted to do a super chat as well okay
yeah all right thank you
yeah we can do it for 30. yeah we can do
that uh just uh drop her a uh private
message
and give her her your shirt size and
your address and all that yeah I think I
have it because I think we sent the
before but send it to me again just in
case like in case I lost it because I
had it all written down up there and I
think maybe Pookie ate it yeah we got
our own ship and service here because
we're considered a business so I'll just
[ __ ] shoot that [ __ ] up as soon as I
got to the detail we'll ship it out in a
couple days yeah I got a scale and all
in the postage printer and all that kind
of stuff yeah Camp guy said I'll send it
again yeah I'd appreciate that just
because like I said faster I know I had
it written down but I I think it'll
speed it up more yeah Pookie took it it
was up there and she took it I don't
know what she did with she probably ate
it because she likes to eat paper
um but yeah so uh what was I talking
about um
uh oh my God I just like again getting
old yeah well we'll talk about a zodiac
well I know that I don't remember where
you were I mean like more specifically
more specifically but um
yeah so this guy I don't know I don't
know I it just kind of feel I feel like
this this crime I can't believe that
they haven't solved it yet you know what
I mean I know it took a long time for
them to solve original Night Stalker
slash Golden State killer they
eventually caught that [ __ ] they
eventually caught BTK but I think he
wanted to get caught but BTK if he
hadn't started like running his mouth
again and like said anymore they
probably wouldn't have caught well I
don't know I don't want to say that
because they might have like genetically
they might have got around and like
caught him the way they caught D'Angelo
yeah but yeah well they never would have
caught D'Angelo without [ __ ] DNA
testing right magic you know he you know
he had no idea that that she would be
around [ __ ] at those ancestry.com
[ __ ] yeah thanks yeah they never
would have caught him he was tactical he
was trained he was a trained cop he yeah
he knew how to evade investigative
techniques and was confident [ __ ] but
he didn't know that new investigative
techniques would emerge and I never
would have thought that
that people were doing ancestry [ __ ]
well yeah you wouldn't you wouldn't
unless you were like a [ __ ] sci-fi
writer yeah wouldn't have like thought
of that yeah they could triangulate your
DNA [ __ ] damn Camp guy said I don't
think they have any DNA from the Zodiac
or maybe just a very small sample yeah
they have a small DNA sample like a
partial DNA sample from uh the stamps
like on the back of the from the back of
the stamps uh the letters that he sent
they can only use it to rule people out
that's pretty much all they can use it
for because it's not a complete profile
but if they have somebody that's a
suspect they can take their DNA and say
oh it's not this guy because the DNA
isn't anything the same but they can't
use it to like pinpoint anybody I don't
think they have enough to do that
so you know what I mean
um all right so I'm you talk for a
minute because I'm gonna run to the
bathroom before we get into this like
too deeply and I have to like interrupt
myself in the middle
yeah um so I'll just I'll just so I can
um bore you guys for a second oh no yeah
because she's gonna the um
I thought I was gonna be gaining a whole
bunch of weight I um I posted two videos
and put them up on my Instagram
I showed them to self sofas God damn she
says there's the of the back of my
calves you know and she goes those are
like rotisserie chickens and I got the
two damn and I [ __ ] started laughing
so I posted them said I'm trying to get
them look like rotisserie chickens see
if I can uh
let me show you guys what I'm talking
about I got them up there but
uh
[ __ ] I gotta [ __ ]
all the like rotisserie chickens
can't really see in this light
[ __ ]
yeah it's not you can't really see it
too well
she's coming back
but uh that's what that [ __ ] did
partially they they looked good to begin
with but it [ __ ] made them business
pop I'm gonna start [ __ ] I need to
start competing competing in are you
showing them are you showing them your
butt leg Yeah she goes this is gonna
look like two asses back there no it
didn't like I told him that he should
draw a thong on it with a marker yeah
yeah yeah
[ __ ] funny well he said it looked
like a roast chicken I said it looks it
looks like a rotisserie chicken that was
and I thought it came up with it it
looks like a butt yeah yeah it's like a
butt yeah
looks like a butt Danny Rowling is
listing a lot of the uh suspects yeah
we're going to talk about most of those
guys uh you know briefly toward the end
but the new guy I'm just
I don't know I I think it's a good case
but I've said that before and I've been
wrong so oh I remember what I was saying
I was talking about uh David Fincher's
movie Zodiac which was based on Robert
graysmith's book
and I think that a lot of people saw
that because Robert graysmith thought
that Arthur Lee Allen was the zodiac
um so consequently the movie kind of
like leans kind of hard it doesn't say
that Arthur Lee Allen is the Zodiac but
kind of like implies that he's the main
suspect
um so I think a lot of people still
think that he's kind of like the main
suspect you know what I mean even though
I will say that the partial DNA profile
that they have from the back of the
stamps of the letters that they're
pretty sure are from the Zodiac
um do not match his DNA and also his
fingerprints and palm prints don't match
the ones that they have for the Zodiac
either so
as uh compelling as a lot of the
circumstantial evidence is against that
guy and he's kind of a [ __ ] bird anyway
but um I don't think he was the Zodiac
though Danny's asked me how to make a
damn pumpkin pie cheesecake there's
gonna be all kinds of recipes on how to
make a pumpkin pie cheesecake it's gonna
be a bunch of different ways man now I
want a pumpkin pie cheesecake maybe we
should make that for Thanksgiving that'd
be good yeah I gotta get a bunch of
cream cheese gotta bake it there's a
bunch of stuff that you need the right
spices you you probably do have to get
some pumpkin puree yeah and and mix in
with there it will work
yeah but I I just you want to pick you
want to pick a good recipe for that I
would use a bake recipe
not a not a no-bake yeah because you can
make no no no big sucks but yeah they're
not yeah they're not quite as good it's
not real cheesecake real cheesecake is
baked yeah
and then refrigerated because it's got
that kind of crust on the outside which
is nice you know that's how you're gonna
get that consistency you'll never get
you'll never duplicate that consistency
without baking it
so you better get ready to get those big
old blocks of Philadelphia cream cheese
go to [ __ ] Costco or say yeah go to
Costco you're gonna need at least two of
those probably not one probably but
you make a lot of cheesecake
that's another thing if you're gonna
make a cheesecake you might as well make
a lot of it
make two of them well that's kind of
true of anything yeah you're gonna make
food but if you're gonna make it make a
lot of them okay because uh you make two
of them make two different ones well
they freeze yeah you can freeze them and
then you can eat them all year and it's
it's just as easy to make three or four
of them than it is to make one
so you might as if you're gonna go
through all that [ __ ] trouble just
let me just make three or four of them
like I said then you're gonna eat them
all you want
okay I said I always buy extra cheese
and cream cheese when it's on sale yeah
probably probably the smart thing you do
because you know
I buy the [ __ ] big old things of
Velveeta
big two bags like I said that makes she
gets mad sometimes but
um I'm not mad I just I I well I like it
in certain applications certain dishes
but in certain other applications not so
much
I eat it because it's protein it's whey
protein it's good for you
people think that Velveeta is bad for
you no go look at the nutrition on the
back it's super high in protein low in
calorie bodybuilders eat a lot of it
it's good it's whey it's not even cheese
that's the thing it's not it's Velveeta
is is Velveeta is not cheese well I
don't even think it says it doesn't
sound the Box around it yeah it's not
cheese it's Velveeta it's Velveeta
they'll call it American cheese but I'm
not sure they even spell cheese the
right way in that well no I think like
the craft singles and stuff like that I
think it has to say like cheese product
or something like that because I think
legally they can't call it cheese if
it's not actual cheese
right it has to doesn't have to have
like a certain percentage of dairy like
to be I think so real cheese like
legally but you could take a big old
block of damn Velveeta and if it's about
the same size as a chicken breast it's
real similar nutritionally to a piece of
a piece a chicken breast you won't get
fat on it or anything
it's it's almost like meat
it's equivalent to meat pretty close
yeah I could eat a whole block of cheese
I eat a whole block of that [ __ ]
I was thinking that I could probably eat
a whole block of like cream cheese
I probably have eaten a whole block of
cream cheese at some point like because
sometimes you take like half the block
and just put that [ __ ] [ __ ] on a on a
bagel man yeah and just yeah just eat it
like that mmm cream cheese is delicious
Zach says can we all agree though cheese
whiz is one of the most what is figuring
figuring yet coolest things ever
invented cream cheese no the cheese whiz
cheese whiz is Velveeta it's the same
thing it's just pressurizing that can
yeah it's a pressurized yeah
yeah it was good to have in the Army
though you could carry it around if I
could squeeze it right here yeah at
least do that when we were good I think
everybody did when they were kids they
had the [ __ ] affects bacon flavor
oh he said disgusting yeah just rather
than figuring no we liked it I liked it
but you can't think of it as cheese it's
just a it's a cheese like cheese like
substance yeah well that's the thing
it's like it's funny because every time
I see one of those videos it's like you
know British people react to like weird
[ __ ] in America the what cheese whiz is
always one of the weird things that they
think but it's like I'm always kind of
like well yeah but cheese whiz isn't
really like people don't eat that every
day though that's one that's more a kid
thing or that's kind of like more
something you take like yeah if you're
like out on the field or camping or
something if you don't like cheese and
crackers that's kind of like I ate it
when I was a kid I haven't eaten it for
probably like 30 years at this point
best use for it is to have it and uh
put it on Triscuits which is a little
wheat crackers it is good on Triscuits
yeah yeah just squish it on there and
spray it and make a pretty pattern and
just put it in your mouth make little
smiley faces if you want to that's what
I used to when I was a kid yeah or on
Ritz crackers let's get on there too or
sh or [ __ ] even on chicken in a Biscuit
of course anything's good on chicken in
a Biscuit I love those [ __ ] things
chicken biscuit crackers
they're like super super Savory chicken
flavored crackers
they still make them I think yeah I
think they still make it kind of like
the chicken flavor packet out of a
packet of ramen yeah sorta sort of like
I said they're really chicken flavor
they're really really rich and savory
yeah I really really like them yeah the
ones made by the damn Keebler really
good they're just they're good you don't
have to put dip or nothing on them you
can just eat them right out of the box
and they're good but it's white trash
food it is yeah I know but that's one
thing that I will drop that's one thing
I will defend we'll know all defend
those two because lemon drop cookies are
good too but chicken in a Biscuit is
like really really good I really like
those Little Debbie cakes oh and yeah
those are good table those are good too
see what we can get we're gonna get
these [ __ ] fat with all these white
trash cuisine
Classics why do we always end up doing
this we're supposed to be talking about
murders like all we do all we do is like
end up talking about like [ __ ] food
all day yeah Hostess pie the little
hostess [ __ ] apple pies and [ __ ]
uh uh [ __ ]
cherry pies
come in a [ __ ] wax paper
gotta hate that song Jesus Christ put
them in a microwave real quick full map
that [ __ ] was good man it's like to
refresh
all right so are should we get into this
go ahead otherwise I'm gonna be here all
night with this [ __ ] and we're gonna be
talking and we're gonna be covering like
the same food [ __ ] that we have we
covered before I know maybe maybe want
to go to the Dollar Store and get all
that damn up there the Dollar General's
got all that white trash see like
tomorrow he's gonna go and get like a
bunch of cookies and [ __ ] like get some
Hostess pies because look what like I
have no snacks we have no snacks in this
house yeah I mean I had some set well
it's I had some snacks I had like some
of those like little
uh little cream cheese crackers I had
like a couple packs of those and I had
like a couple granola bars but they're
all gone now so we can go get some I
think all I got well I don't know I
don't really like to keep that much
stuff around because I'll eat it cans of
Vienna sausages no I don't want that
okay they got a lot of that over there
right now it's looking I think all I
have left is like a couple like things
of cup noodles and then I have like a
big jar of pickles in the fridge
then I go in there and get like with a
fork you know you guys should have seen
it man [ __ ] David who's in the
comment sections right now last time I
went to the club and he showed up
he had a [ __ ] huge [ __ ] can of
Colt 45 Malt Liquor that's right
I had inspired David go down here and
[ __ ] hang out it was David me and
Billy D Williams all hanging out
together in his mind while he's [ __ ]
drinking that [ __ ] cool sexy Colt 45
he's like this shit's good [ __ ] it
that's right you only got it if you only
got a buck or so man you want to get a
[ __ ] Colt 45 and the high gravity was
pretty good too the black can it was
pretty good yeah I liked their original
one better but yeah they were both okay
well we that's I did a review on it yeah
let's go back and look at it it was you
know we too we immediately like forgot
because remember how we were gonna keep
doing the side track shows we were gonna
go get like weird booze and treats so
like we did that for like two or three
weeks and then we forgot about it yeah
we can go back and do it well I gotta go
back to the [ __ ] Country Store over
there and get it I want to get some more
of those Micheladas Modelo michelada
yeah those were good real good I like
those a lot yeah and Khan was like well
of course it was good it's Modelo man
that's our best brand yeah [ __ ] who
told he was like who told you that was
shitty stuff up there at the [ __ ]
Country Store they didn't know they
never drank it they don't know they're
just like yeah yeah no [ __ ] Modelo
was good real good Mexican good Mexican
beer a lot better than that [ __ ] Dos
Equis [ __ ] Takata and all that
[ __ ] no Modelo real good don't be
asking like no rednecks in the middle of
nowhere like we know like what's good I
don't know what a michelada is
that's what I mean yeah they don't know
[ __ ] don't ask for anything I mean if
you want like some trashy ass booze then
ask him about that but yeah other than
that they probably don't know
you know all right go ahead all right go
ahead get it over so let's get it over
with that's thanks Tom that that really
makes me want to do the show you're
inspiring I haven't said I haven't slept
like a normal human being in a couple
weeks
ever since like a normal human being
yeah I'm always kind of like in a state
of [ __ ] tiredness pretty much because
I wake up early like pretty much every
single morning yeah I know man I try to
get some and she's already in here
[ __ ] working
Because by the time you get up I've
already been up for like three or four
hours
I'm trying to get laid man it's like I'm
in the middle of some [ __ ] it's like a
work day I don't know when I hit one
here I don't want to hear that I'm just
saying that's your that's your fault you
sleep trying to get my [ __ ] jump on a
dick
[Laughter]
man's just a man you know
mortal man yeah okay
whatever okay come on let's go all right
let's are we really gonna talk about
this are you are you gonna contribute
don't be weird I'm gonna contribute man
okay don't be a ass I'm not gonna be an
ass I'm not gonna be more C I'm not
gonna be gay nothing I'm just gonna be
straight you actually you could be
Morrissey that would be more yeah that
would be funny but um
I got Morrissey a couple times she saw
it man I was [ __ ] emotional like she
just settle me down
yeah it's yeah it's true there's nothing
wrong so I mean you know get emotional
if you're getting emotional
no I was there you were getting emotions
it's kind of resolved now oh I'm kind of
getting more used to it but I'm not
supposed to have this [ __ ] hormonal
profile in there it's Gotta it's got to
come out I adapted to it but it still
doesn't feel good it doesn't feel right
yeah yeah well I mean you know you just
kind of get you kind of build up of like
okay well I guess this is how it is you
know so I'm just gonna stay like this
you know
so it kind of its impact kind of wears
off
[Laughter]
it'll be over in a week or so the more
you win yeah they're saying modelo's a
good beer
he's saying to try the original
michelada yeah they didn't have it
didn't have the original one
they were real good
the chili ones
Zach said Tom's failure in that area is
he isn't flirting in the Hubbard voice
well he's probably tried that at some
point I feel like that sounds like some
[ __ ] you would do what's that like
flirting in BTK voices yeah like that
yeah that does kind of sound like
something you would do actually
no it's not so much that like I said
it's just you know I get up really early
because I'm just used to getting up
really early because I always you know I
always had to get up early to go to work
so I usually just get up at
6 37 and you know coming here do my bike
you know do work and stuff like that and
then like hours later like he'll wake up
and expect me to come back to bed I'm
like I've been up for like an hour I've
already done bike I already took a
shower and it's like I already did all
this stuff and it's like dude I got [ __ ]
to do uh all right so let's start
talking about like I said we're just
going to
uh go back over the Zodiac case
um you know and then like at the end
we'll talk about like some of the new
suspects and the new developments and
all that kind of stuff uh you know it'll
be a fun discussion even though I
typically like what listener Patrick and
his girlfriend would be coming down to
Florida one of the uh uh sometime around
this and I said we need to swing by you
can be on the show and they [ __ ] want
to be on the show that's the uh uh the
[ __ ] kind of little goth couple
I'll show you Patrick he's the he was
that guy with the dreadlocks and his
little golf girlfriend stuff maybe
they'll come to mannequins with us or
something yeah they're coming down and
visit relatives in a while [ __ ] we got
to decide too because the weekend before
Halloween
there are two Halloween parties
mannequins is having a Halloween party
on Saturday okay well actually they're
having a Halloween party both nights
okay Friday night they're doing uh like
a Rob Zombie themed I think it's called
hillbilly Halloween or something and
then Saturday night they're doing
horrorween okay but Friday night uh
Memento Moria Barbarella is also doing a
Halloween party because Halloween's on
the Monday but we can't hit them both so
that's what I'm saying so we have to
kind of like decide which one we're
gonna go to we'll worry about it when we
get there yeah I'm just saying I just
found out today that it's gonna be
bigger at mannequins
that probably will be good
and be more private the thing about it
is like if we go to the Halloween at
Memento Mori I probably won't because
we'll be doing the Side Tracks before
that so I probably won't wear a costume
to that now if we go to mannequins on
Saturday night then I probably will do
the costume and I'm gonna do the costume
again on Monday too like for the
haunting show all right then we hit them
both I guess I mean I don't we don't
necessarily have to go to both I'm just
saying because I know we're about the
money situation too
that's what I'm saying it's kind of
expensive yeah and I'll be like worn out
yeah so but I don't know we'll figure
this like I said we still got a little
while okay towards the end of the month
didn't it it's the 19th I can't believe
it's almost Halloween already yeah all
right at least I got most of my costume
stuff like I ordered the stuff for my
costume but like most of it's here but
there's still like a couple people
what's the costume
hey it's like it's a surprise all right
because I just I want to do like the
show on Halloween day like okay which is
the Monday all right and then I'll have
it on like okay that day all right
hopefully like I said we'll go out that
weekend so I'll get to practice it Okay
you know so like because I think I know
how it's gonna turn out but you never
know like I might [ __ ] it up you know
but I think it's gonna look good all
right so we're going to go over the
Zodiac case uh you know so
we'll see I know a lot of people are
familiar with it but whatever okay so
now I will say that there were several
murders that in later years have maybe
been attributed to the Zodiac but
they're not really sure if the Zodiac
did them or not
um you know there's a handful of those
and I'll get into those like later on
even though some of them happened
earlier like some of them happened like
in the early like early 60s so we'll
kind of get into that it's I kind of
want to talk first about
the you know like canonical ones I guess
and then like later on we'll talk about
some of the possible ones that have been
like brought up as like maybe being the
zodiac
so the first canonical zodiac murder or
the lake Herman Road murders
this happened a few days before
Christmas in
1968. uh it was actually December 20th
so it was 17 year old named David
Faraday uh and in his new girlfriend is
Betty Lou Jensen uh he picked her up
they were gonna go out on a date they
actually went to high school together
and this was actually their first date
um and actually the first date that
Betty Lou had ever been on she was only
17 or 16 years old at the time
so David Faraday actually borrowed his
mom's car which is a Rambler station
wagon for the date
and they had actually initially planned
they were going to go to like this
Christmas concert at the high school
um they decided not to do that and they
went instead to visit friends then they
went and had dinner at a restaurant and
then they headed up to Lake Herman Road
which was like a you know a Lover's Lane
type area
so they parked at the turnout uh
sometime around 10 15 something like
that
about 45 minutes later uh a neighbor
like a person who lived in the area a
woman named Stella Borges
she discovered their bodies
now it looked as though David had been
trying to get out of the vehicle
um when he was shot in the head with a
22 caliber long rifle Betty Lou had been
running away from the scene uh the
killer shot her five times in the back
her body was found about 30 feet away
from the car
so the from the forensic evidence that
have been uh gathered at the scene it
looked as though another vehicle had
pulled up alongside the Rambler and that
whoever was in this car had fired at the
car's Windows like possibly to get them
to like run out of the car
now even though both of the victims were
killed with the same weapon and there
were uh 10 22 caliber long rifle shell
casings like found in the area there
also appeared to be a bullet hole from a
38 caliber firearm in the roof panel of
the Rambler so at first the cops thought
that maybe there had been two attackers
which I don't know if anybody has ever
kind of like put I think somebody just
said in the chat like a little while ago
that oh maybe there were multiple
Killers but I don't know if they met you
know they were multiple Killers like on
each crime or if there were like
multiple Killers doing some of the
different crimes like separately did
they ever explain the 38 caliber hole
I don't think they ever did not that I
know he had a gun in there and tried to
defend himself he fired off around
that's possible that's possible and
after he killed him he went in there and
he got that 38. that's possible took it
with him I would suspect that that's
probably what happened he started taking
fire and [ __ ] grabbed a gun [ __ ]
was trying to maybe level it down he
[ __ ] jerked off a [ __ ] round and
went through the ceiling and but he was
killed by the time
he was able to level it at the at the
attacker
the attacker went in there and got the
gun
that actually makes more sense to me
then I mean unless somebody was shooting
at the car like at some previous time
previous time but that sounds like more
likely he had a gun in there with him
for self-defense and [ __ ] when he
started taking fire he grabbed the gun
[ __ ] fired off jerked off around as
as he was getting shot as he was getting
shot probably that that actually makes
more sense and like you said maybe the
killer like took then he took the gun
that gun
later on that yeah that's possible
that's possible yeah so uh you have to
think at this point uh you know this was
the first canonical crime as I said
there had been some crimes similar to
this like prior but they were like in
different areas and they'd been like
years before so nobody like really
connected them so nobody knew like
nobody had the hindsight they didn't
know that this was obviously going to be
a serial killer
um so to them it just seemed like this
completely senseless murder like these
two teenagers were just sitting in a car
and like somebody came and like started
[ __ ] shooting at them for seemingly
no reason so obviously the first thing
they did was they started investigating
um you know people that they knew like
people that maybe had an a reason to
kill them or whatever and they were
thinking well maybe it was jealousy so
they actually investigated I mean to
that end a fellow student of theirs like
at the high school who
um was supposedly like kind of jealous
because I guess he wanted to go out with
Betty Lou Johnson and like so he was
jealous of uh David Faraday's
relationship with her and uh supposedly
this person had like had an argue
argument with David Faraday like on the
same day when they were killed
um and he did like so they questioned a
couple of people in that line that they
thought maybe had reason to to do it but
honestly like neither of these people
you know both of them had Alibis and
really there wasn't any other evidence
to you know kind of uh do go any further
with that so really the case just didn't
go anywhere for like several months
after and
it would actually be July of the
following year before they would figure
out like because that's when like uh you
know other murders started happening the
letters phone calls all that kind of
stuff
um that they would be aware that this
was actually like a serial killer you
know what I mean
so the next Camp guys is for some reason
I think you can shoot a 22 long rifle
from a pistol yeah of course you can and
he goes so many of us have said that
they didn't have you couldn't do that
and he had a Ruger eight shot 22 pistol
right next to his bed yeah
oh yeah 22 long rifle is available in
all kinds of pistols one of my favorite
little
Pistols that I ever owned was like an
early 60s 1960s model French MAB in 22
22 long rifle was a little commercial
model set up like a little combat pistol
that thing was sweet it was like 10
round magazine and it was just old
school
ugly looking kind of ugly looking French
never made anything that looked pretty
but it was just this
funky looking little thing
and uh accurate man kind of like that
Ruger you're talking about but clunkier
you can look it up French mab a 22 long
rifle pistol 1960s you see it funny
looking it was sweet real sweet well
made
okay good
all right so the next canonical murder
was the Blue Rock Springs murder
this took place on July 4th of
1969. uh there was a 22 year old Darlene
Farren and her boyfriend who was 19 his
name was Michael Maggio she actually
like picked him up for a date it was
Fourth of July so they were you know
going out and doing that kind of stuff
so they actually drove to Blue Rock
Springs Park in Vallejo California uh
which was only about four miles away
from the spot on Lake Hermann Road where
the Faraday Jensen murder had taken
place at this point this was more than
six months earlier
so Darlene and Michael are sitting in
the car another car uh comes into the
parking lot and pulled up next to their
car which was a Corvair
and for a little while and then drove
off again uh they didn't really think
that much about it you know it's like oh
well okay they left but then about 10
minutes later the car came back and
parked directly behind their car so that
they couldn't get out
uh a man then got out of the car came
toward Darlene's car carrying a
flashlight and a pistol uh the man
shined the flashlight through the
passenger side window uh and which
blinded both of them and then shot into
the car five times Michael Maggio was
hit in the chest the neck and the face
and most of the bullets this is [ __ ]
horrible most of the bullets like also
went all the way through him and into
Darlene who was in the driver's seat it
was a nine millimeter wasn't it I
believe this was a nine millimeter yeah
he's probably using nine millimeter full
metal jacket rounds was just standard
[ __ ] that you would get at any gun store
kind of a military style route a lot of
penetration in nine in nine millimeter
pistol well clearly yeah it slips in and
out doesn't do a whole lot of damage it
kind of looks like an ice pick wood
but it goes through bone and and Flash
pretty well goes through armor pretty
well which is why militaries liked it
low recoil small kind of light pistol
caliber but good good round
uh it's funny that it over penetrated
him and the over penetrated rounds is
what killed her
yeah okay he lives she did not okay
okay and he was in in that same vehicle
had the 38 caliber hole in the roof no
that was the first that's the first one
this is the second one this is the
difference okay completely different
right yeah because I was saying why
didn't he explain why couldn't he
explain that I think that first one was
a guy trying to defend himself yeah
maybe he parked in a Lover's Lane and
had a 38 handy to defend him and he
couldn't get to it in time or couldn't
respond it got crept up well you're not
really expecting somebody just walk up
to your car and start shooting right I
mean that's how often does that happen
yeah he's lucky he's lucky just to get
off around
um if that's what happened yeah probably
that does sound like pretty probably
what happened he's because he's making
out with a hot girl this is back in the
day and you could be young and have a
pistol back in the day and this is what
60s yeah this is late 60s yeah I think I
think an 18 year old could own a pistol
in in the 60s in the United States later
on it got changed to 21. you can own a
rifle but you couldn't own a pistol and
still they wouldn't he wouldn't have
been in trouble in the 60s to have a
pistol you'd tell the cop well I'm just
trying to hear yeah okay you go well
that [ __ ] was legal you know but uh well
the first guy was 17. David Faraday was
17. they still wouldn't have thrown the
book yeah I'm just saying that that's it
was a very minor that was that's not a
big deal in the United States but he he
what he did he's out there screwing that
girl and he had that pistol handy just
in case which is that's a good boy I'd
do the same thing you're in the darkened
area by yourself [ __ ] somebody could
creep up on you and they did
you know like I said it's very rare but
it's very rare but made precautions you
know yeah but it does happen you know
obviously you're on the edge of society
there's no law enforcement out there you
got to cover your own back and he's
protecting that girl that's what I think
happened
that's what I would have done
you know yeah and um yeah I think he got
a round off as he was getting shot
and then he stole then then the Zodiac
stole that pistol because you wouldn't
leave that you'd take it
you use it as a [ __ ] weapon later
yeah
so yeah so uh so he shoots into the car
like I said he hit uh Michael Maggio and
then the bullets went through and hit
Darlene uh at which points the Zodiac
turned around and headed back to his own
car but Michael who was actually still
alive and was still conscious uh even
though he'd been shot multiple times he
made a noise like he groomed in pain
essentially and the killer came back and
shot again like shot two more times uh
two bullets each into Michael and
Darlene and then took off in his car but
he still lived Michael Mejo lived yeah
damn Darlene did not tough little dude
yeah Darlene did not but but he did now
less than an hour after that
the Vallejo Police Department got a
phone call from a man who in a very
monotone voice told them that he wanted
to report a murder
he told them where the bodies could be
found said that the couple had been
killed with a nine millimeter Luger and
also claimed responsibility for the
earlier Faraday Jensen murders which
like I said had taken place like a
little bit more than six months earlier
you can let me clarify something
they said nine millimeter Luger
that can confuse somebody
they would say Well they're talking
about the the Luger po8 Pistol no
the name of the caliber is nine
millimeter Parabellum
all right it has been called other
things over the years nine millimeter
Luger line nine millimeter para uh and I
think that's about it but what they're
talking about is nine millimeter
Parabellum doesn't mean it was shot with
a Luger it's unlikely he was shot with a
[ __ ] uh po8 Luger which is that
classic German pistol those were pretty
rare
and they weren't very reliable
it was probably something a lot more
common in the United States at that time
like a a Browning high power pistols
probably what it was or
um Browning was it called
uh model 35 uh it was probably a [ __ ]
Browning high power if not like an old
Surplus Walther
um P-38 those were a lot of those were
around
those original old German lugers were
always collectors items so they were
always very expensive and they were kind
of finicky it wasn't really a normal
nine millimeter load that they shot it
was a lighter version of it with a I
think a 92 grain round bullet that was
kind of shorter and a little more
rounder anything once you got outside of
the real old
version of that caliber it wasn't
reliable with it
so I've seen reenactments of this
[ __ ] crime scene and he's carrying a
po8 Luger because the cop said that they
were shot with nine millimeter Luger
they met nine millimeter parabella
guarantee it was not that pistol it's
probably more like a Browning high power
those were common and a lot better
okay so that's just for our gun Freaks
and our people who are sleuthing out
there
probably not a Luger probably a Browning
high power
for every one loot for every one lugers
there were about a 200 or 300 Browning
High powers out there so statistically
it's going to be that
pistol was a lot
more popular
so this phone call was traced uh and it
was discovered that it had originated
from a gas station pay phone that was
only a couple of blocks away from the
police station they actually did I
believe get a partial handprint like a
palm print off of the uh phone you know
what I mean so uh so the authorities get
to the scene
uh when they got there both Darlene and
Michael were still alive but Darlene
Farren died as soon as she got to the
hospital Michael Maggio uh survived and
was actually able to give a description
of the killer to the police I can't
believe he [ __ ] lived he got shot
like a bunch of times like in the head
and in the face and [ __ ] like that
so he said he described the attacker as
a somewhat heavy set white man he said
maybe like 200 pounds maybe heavier
um and he also said probably in his late
20s
um average height light brown short
curly or wavy hair that's how he
described him
so uh despite this you know good
description and all of the physical
evidence that they got from the scene
um they really couldn't uh you know
police didn't really have any luck
tracking down the dude and you know uh
it's starting to look like a serial
killer with a particular ammo like
somebody targeting couples in cars just
like randomly
uh less than a month after Darlene
Farren died after this attack
um that's when the Zodiac started
writing his crazy ass coded letters that
you know ensured that he would be
remembered like forever I kind of feel
like well because I kind of feel like
there'd been other crimes like this
before like other lovers lane type
murders and I kind of feel like the
reason everybody remembers the zodiac is
one because he never got caught and two
because of all the crazy [ __ ] letters
and ciphers and [ __ ] you know what I
mean because it added like a sense of
mystery to it and the Zodiac I mean
that's a
you know everybody likes like that it's
kind of like a PR kind of thing yeah
it's just like [ __ ] man that's what I'm
saying Panache he had [ __ ] stage
presence
okay he's trying to make a character for
himself so he was remembered
yeah that's what I'm saying because I
mean it's weird because I you know I
write about a lot of True Crimes and
sometimes I'll come across
some crime that I'm like shocked is not
better known because it's like so weird
or like so [ __ ] up and I'm like why
isn't this better known about but it's
always kind of like I don't know it has
to do with
just I don't know it's this kind of
stuff like I said codes everybody loves
that everybody loves like a serial
killer with like a cool Punchy name
Christopher Bell says well maybe he was
a World War II veteran and maybe he had
a po8 most of the poets inside the
United States were bought here
commercially pre-war all right
um a war time POA Luger would have been
a collector's item because it would have
been Nazi proof marked you wouldn't use
that in a crime no [ __ ] no that's a
collector's item
uh be too valuable that's not what it
was it was something like a Browning
high power or a star model B there were
a lot of those around at that time and
you could get a star model B which is a
copy of a Spanish copy of a basically a
cult 1911 but it was a little bit the
dimensions were a little bit tighter and
it was in nine millimeter good pistol it
was that the star B was a good pistol
um especially for the money but those
are real cheap so it was probably
something like a star b or if you had a
little bit more money a brownie high
power
far more common and better really than a
po8
lugers were pre-World War One technology
they were around for a long time let me
go toggle action you don't want that let
me go get uh refill uh Juan says hello
Tom and Jenny hello uh and murder Hornet
is here uh so everybody's here
everybody's showing up Samantha
worthless [ __ ] says I keep a dildo
next to my bed to beat off attackers
with
that's pretty funny maybe it'll chill
him out maybe all right so like I said I
kind of feel like the reason one of the
reasons that he's remembered is because
of these crazy ass [ __ ] letters and
codes that he sent so this is when this
started happening August 1st 1969. uh
they get one of the first of the
infamous zodiac letters and this one
actually showed up simultaneously at the
offices of the San Francisco Examiner
the San Francisco Chronicle and the
Vallejo Times Herald like they all got
copies of it so the writer uh whoever
wrote this these letters uh took credit
for both the murders of David Faraday
and Betty Lou Johnson uh the lake
Hermann Road murders and the attack at
Blue Rock Springs Park um in which
Darlene farron died and Michael Mejo was
wounded the writer also threatened that
if you don't publish this letter on the
front page of your newspaper I'm going
to kill 12 more people that's what he
said like that's what he threatened
also uh the letters contained a third of
a weird cryptogram that the writer
claimed would reveal his identity if
solved spoiler alert uh it didn't but I
think most people know that now at this
point like the cops and the newspaper
editors were like look this could one
this could be a hoax and two um if this
is the serial killer we don't want to
like accede to his seed to his demands
because that would be [ __ ] up so they
said what we're gonna do is we'll kind
of like do a compromise it's like we'll
print the [ __ ] but not on the front page
um like the chronicle said we'll publish
it but on page four you know what I mean
uh so and they also had like a statement
from the Vallejo police chief like next
to it like talking about what it was and
everything like that
um and basically like the uh the police
chief was like hey
um we don't really know if you're really
the killer so we're just gonna put you
on page four but if you really are the
killer then send us more proof like we
need more proof you know what I'm saying
so that's what he said
so the other two newspapers pretty much
like did the same thing because I'm
assuming like they called each other
like what are you guys gonna do you know
what I mean
um so uh you know it should be noted too
that the 12 murders that the Zodiac said
was gonna happen if the letters weren't
published on the first page yeah that
didn't happen
uh August 7th
um another letter came into the San
Francisco Examiner and this particular
letter was the first one where the
killer actually referred to himself as
the Zodiac it was like dear editor this
is the Zodiac that's how it started out
and not only did it um kind of like
really reiterate the previous claim that
he made
um that if you crack the code like it'll
tell you my name like it'll tell you who
I am
um also in this letter it actually
provided details about the lake Herman
Road and Blue Rock Springs Park killings
that had not been made public so at this
point uh the police were pretty sure
that this was the actual person that had
committed the crimes because they knew
details that were not released now the
day that this letter turned up at the
examiner uh there was a couple named
Donald and Betty Hardin and they were
from Salinas and they told the police
that they had mostly deciphered The
Zodiacs uh cryptogram which they had
published in the paper
um unfortunately but probably not
surprisingly the translated message did
not reveal the Zodiac's identity because
what fun would that be but was simply a
very rambling and uh very uh chilling
dispatch in which the writer extolled
the virtues of killing calling it fun
and the most thrilling experience even
better than getting your rocks off with
a girl uh yeah and it's it's spelled
horribly too I have to like if you go on
Wikipedia like it tells you like what
all of them say there's like a whole um
and they someone's transcribed them all
too like you can go and like on a
wikisource or whatever
and dude could not [ __ ] spell to save
his [ __ ] life I will say that's funny
how he could do all those ciphers and
could think up all that kind of [ __ ] but
he couldn't spell
unless he was doing it on purpose to
make it harder to harder but I don't
know but I I kind of feel like that's
not the case because a lot of the
misspellings were um he did them over
and over again were consistent yeah so I
think he was just a dummy that didn't
like know how limited education yeah I
think so yeah
um trying to be more than what he was
yeah this is definitely that kind of
[ __ ] yeah I feel like trying I
want to be a real tryhard but wannabe
yeah trying to be the Joker basically
before the Joker was a thing like I said
this is like I hate it's better and I've
said this on other shows it's bad enough
if you're a serial killer but then you
have to be like a [ __ ] Edge Lord
about it too Jesus Christ
[ __ ] man
well some of them like that's just like
that's just like a [ __ ] cherry on the
[ __ ] Sunday right yeah Jesus you're just
compounding your [ __ ] error
so
uh yeah so basically also in this uh you
know translated thing
uh it's like he he said that he was
killing people in order to collect
slaves for his use in the afterlife
do I think he really believed that I
don't know I know I doubt it but I mean
when we talk about like one of the newer
uh suspects
there might be like what where that came
from you know what I'm saying good uh
now the last 18 letters of this the 408
letter uh cryptogram have still not been
deciphered so I don't know if it
actually means anything or if you just
put some [ __ ] on the end like to confuse
everybody or whatever but as far as I
know it's still not deciphered like I
said other ones got deciphered well all
the other ones have been to say foreign
one of them took a long time so I bet
you there's something there
yeah there might be he just changed his
methods I guess to encode it
they'll figure it out eventually
probably but it's going to be more
[ __ ]
yeah that's what I mean it's like I
don't really like I get that it's kind
of like a challenge like because there's
a code and you want to figure it out I
get that but they figured out like his
other ones and it's just like a bunch of
[ __ ] and it's like I'm sure it's
gonna say the same [ __ ] as like as
the other one said you know what I mean
so it's like you're gonna get all
excited about it and then it's like well
yeah it's not gonna have his name in it
that's the same crap as like as [ __ ]
said before Christopher Bell said bad
speller codes Luger sounds like a World
War II veteran to me no
no you misunderstand it
they said the caliber was nine
millimeter Luger but that's the same as
nine millimeter parabella all right and
no not at all
it's not going to be a Luger's the po8
Luger was rare back then and worth money
World War II veteran [ __ ] if he had
it he would know what he'd had he
wouldn't use that guns are cheap in the
United States but now Luger wasn't the
Luger was never cheap
you could take that Luger and sell it
and buy [ __ ] five hot Browning High
powers especially if it was Nazi proof
marked that's a collector's item you
don't use that
unless you're a crazy person yeah he
wouldn't have it
if he would if he wouldn't have that
he was crazy you know what I mean he
just wouldn't have it if it was a World
War II veteran he wouldn't be crazy
enough to do that
you go I'm not using that that's worth
something you know he he knows he you go
down there for 75 dollars get a [ __ ]
star model B
that's how that's what they cost in the
60s 75 you know when it was even a
better pistol than the Luger
all right so the next canonical murder
was the Lake Berryessa murder which to
me this one was like the creepiest one
and honestly if you haven't seen the
David Fincher movie Zodiac this scene
was [ __ ] terrifying like the way that
he shot it because it looked exactly
like what you would picture it would
look like in real life and it just like
oh my God it stressed me out like so
much that scene from this [ __ ] movie
because I could imagine that that's
probably exactly what it looked like in
real life and it just like weirded me
out so uh so this was Brian Hartnell and
Cecilia Shepard
and they were spending uh September 27th
uh which was a Saturday having a pic uh
having a picnic on the shores of Lake
Berryessa which is in Napa County in
California
now they're laying around on their
blanket like on the shore or whatever
and uh this kind of husky white male uh
browned average height wearing a black
Executioner's Hood
um which he had kind of like some Grammy
brown hair like coming from underneath
he sort of like approached them
he was carrying what appeared to be a 45
and also had a square of fabric on his
chest okay that had a white cross hair
symbol there it is was anybody shot with
this thing not in this okay it appeared
to be a 45. it appeared to be a 45.
they're talking about the 1911. okay the
star model B looked like a 1911.
they use it as a as a fake 1911 in
movies all the time
guarantee it was not a 1911 it was a
star model b and nine millimeter okay
the same when he shot those other people
with it's a star that's what he used
so I've got that it's been eliminated
all this [ __ ] about World War II
veterans with lugers no
no in World War II the only German
forces that used the po8 Luger was the
kriegs marine the the Navy and there
were only a few of them
the POA liquor was a World War one
weapon and pre-World War one they they
used it before that it was two out of
date so that answered it I've solved
that you can go ahead and write it down
on your [ __ ] calendar on this day Tom
has identified the [ __ ] murder weapon
all right it was a star model B
it's what it was in nine millimeter
okay okay so well I've never done I'm
never sure if you're yeah I'm done it's
a storm I'll be because they said it
appeared to be a 45. they're talking
about the 1911. but this the star model
B appears to be a 1911. it isn't it's a
copy of the 1911 in nine millimeter
you can look it up on the internet and
that's what he used that's what he's
using to abduct this couple and that's
what he used to kill that other couple
and he shot the other two with it too
didn't he
yeah he didn't he didn't shoot these two
he didn't shoot those two but he shot
the other two couples with that there it
was nine millimeter both of them right
it's a star model B that's what he's
using
okay so he kind of so he comes out like
I said he's got the Executioner sewed on
he has like a square of fabric kind of
like pinned or sewed on his chest or
something like that and it has like the
white Crosshair symbol on it which like
I said later became associated with him
specifically
man told
that he had recently escaped from a
Montana prison where he had murdered a
guard and he asked for money and he
wanted their car uh he said the car that
he was driving was too hot that's what
he told them
uh he then brought out a whole bunch of
plastic clotheslined and he told Cecilia
that she had to tie up her boyfriend now
she tied him up but she tied him up
really Loosely which which is probably
what you would do
um but the killer like obviously like
went and checked and was like yeah he
tightened it up uh and then tied her up
as well now at this point both Brian and
Cecilia thought well this was just a
robbery he just wanted money and he
wanted their car and then it would be
over so they said okay well whatever
just like take what you want but then
once they were tied up and just like
laying there they were like on their
stomachs uh the guy just began stabbing
them
um just like laughing as he did it Brian
got stabbed six times uh Cecilia at
least 10 times maybe more yes nine
millimeter is nine by nineteen that's
the same as nine millimeter Parabellum
nine millimeter Luger it's been called a
bunch of different things nine by
nineteen and the what the in what
they're talking about is a 9 by 19
pistol that looks like the 1911. all
right that's a star model B the star
model B was a nine millimeter copy of
the Colt 1911 and that's what he's using
guarantee 100 percent
okay
so so the Zodiac then just left them on
the blanket like bleeding and walked up
to where Brian's car was it was carnegia
and on the door of the car he drew his
Crosshair symbol with a black marker and
then he wrote
um some dates on it the date of the lake
Herman Road murder uh the date of the
Blue Rock Springs attack and then the
current date uh you know this attack and
he had a notation at the end that just
said buy knife like that's how he killed
them by knife uh and then he basically
just like disappeared now uh Brian and
Cecilia were actually still alive
um when the killer you know vanished
um and they were screaming obviously and
they like a guy and his son that were
nearby they'd been fishing they came and
like helped him out called the cops
called an ambulance stuff like that so
the victims were actually able to give a
very detailed description of the
perpetrator and a rundown of exactly
what had happened
um sadly though Cecilia actually lost
conscious on the way to the hospital and
went into a coma and then she died two
days later uh Brian Hartnell actually
survived uh you know he'd been stabbed
six times
now at a little past 7 30 p.m on these
this same evening
their uh phone call came into the Napa
County Sheriff's Office
and this one the caller claimed
responsibility for that days he called
it the double murder because I guess
when he called he wasn't aware that both
of the victims were still alive like
when he called like I said Cecilia did
die later but like two days later and
Brian actually survived so he called it
like um a double murder and he had
actually they traced the call and he had
actually phoned from a car wash which
was only a couple blocks away from the
sheriff's office which was actually
about 30 miles away from the crime scene
so they found the pay phone where the
call had been made from and the receiver
was still hanging off of the hook and
they did get a palm print I think I said
before that they got a palm print from
the other phone which I don't think they
did they got a palm print from this
phone uh though but they never did match
it
to a suspect now uh so the cops were
still working on this crime
um two weeks later the guy struck again
although at this point he did something
a little bit different
so this was the Presidio Heights murder
28 year old cab driver Paul Stein picked
up a dude near Union Square in San
Francisco uh this was October 11 1969.
so the guy who gets in the taxi asked to
be taken to a particular intersection in
Presidio Heights neighborhood in San
Francisco
when he got there like when Paul Stein
parked his taxi at the destination uh
the passenger suddenly pulled out a nine
millimeter pistol and shot Paul Stein
once in the head
then he wiped down the interior of the
cab took Paul's wallet and his keys and
tore off a piece of the victim's bloody
shirt and took it with him
now there had been three teenagers who'd
been like across the street and they saw
something like weird going on like in
the cab they called the cops probably
like a little bit before 10 o'clock at
night they described a white man in his
late 20s you know same as the other
people had reported and said the suspect
had started walking North uh in the
direction of the park like uh the park
that's known as the Presidio
now so one of the first officers on the
scene was named Dan uh falc I think is
how you pronounce his last name he also
spotted a white male who was walking on
the north side of the street
um although he wasn't sure if that was
the same guy because that dude was older
like maybe 35 40 years old
and uh at any rate at this point like by
the time he saw that guy he didn't
actually go after that guy because the
radio dispatcher who had actually taken
the teenager's call mistakenly reported
to to the officers that were reporting
to the scene that the suspect was black
which he was not he was a white guy
so uh once they sorted all that
confusion out though uh the teenagers
were actually able to give a pretty
detailed description of the man that
they had seen in the taxi
um so that's what they did the kind of
famous
um you know sketches from now at first
this crime was actually not linked to
the previous zodiac crimes because
obviously the modus operandi was a lot
different I mean this is just somebody
that shot a cab driver and not like
somebody that was coming up in like a
Lover's Lane style murder
now three days after Paul Stein was
killed uh the San Francisco Chronicle
got another letter from the Zodiac
um in which he took credit for killing
Paul Stein uh and the envelope also had
that bloodied Swatch of the shirt like
that he had taken from the crime scene
like to prove that he was the one that
had done it
the letter also mocked the cops for not
being able to catch him and said that oh
the PO those police sketches won't help
you because I was wearing a disguise and
those drawings don't look anything like
me I don't know if that's true or not
but you know yeah yeah right I know it's
like they're you can't believe yeah you
do you can't believe anything it's not
me you can't believe anything yeah I've
had a disguise on yeah so right yeah it
showed it really is and like I said even
if he's still alive he's probably like
[ __ ] 90 years old by now what's he
gonna do what's funny is that he thinks
he's come hit me with his walker he
thinks he's smarter than everybody else
he's smart enough to evade detection but
he's not that [ __ ] smart well you
don't have to be that smart to evade
detection to be fair no oh oh those
sketches yeah that's not me I don't look
like that I had a disguise on dude yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here dude he looks
just like that yeah he probably yeah
he's just trying to like you know
confuse the situation
uh this same letter also threatened to
shoot out the front tire of a random
school bus and kill the children as they
came quote unquote bouncing out of the
vehicle he never did it so that he never
did he never did it because I mean
thankfully but he never did it because
it was outside his outside his skill set
he couldn't do it I saw his little
[ __ ] diagram where he was drawn light
sensors to fire off the [ __ ]
Explosive Rounds when the [ __ ] bus
goes in the way like like like any other
car wouldn't trigger that and you know
what I mean [ __ ] and where is he
gonna get these light sensors and [ __ ]
he's gonna get him out of what garage
door opening [ __ ] technology and he's
gonna set that [ __ ] up on the side of
the road what cars are driving by now
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah this is
one of those [ __ ] I kind of
feel like a lot of serial killers fall
into this because BTK was like this too
yeah where it's like well they're yeah
they're very fantasy prone and they
think they're smarter than everybody
else in the world yeah this will scare
them I'm gonna tell him I'm gonna make
an atomic bomb and I'm gonna do this and
that and I'm gonna do that and I'm gonna
put [ __ ] cooties in it
it's a cootie ball yeah yeah just you
know just forget the [ __ ] out of here
dude oh my God I wanna now I want a
t-shirt that says if you look at [ __ ]
that actually works it's used by [ __ ]
conventional militaries and it's very
robust and very simple technology it's
not high tech at all
it's got wires there's no [ __ ] IR
[ __ ]
there's no way of tricking tricking
things like the Claymore Mine it's an
explosive thing with a blasting cap on
the end of a [ __ ] wire with a switch
a battery you know it's not
like it's not high-tech [ __ ] the thing
about it though it's that I know I
understand that from a law enforcement
perspective like any time one of these
dumbasses like makes a threat like that
you have to take it seriously because
what if on the off chance like God
forbid like something like that does
happen then it's like then your ass is
going to be on the line because you
didn't prevent it so they do have to
take it seriously because you never know
like what that person's capabilities are
but 99 times out of 100 like they're
just talking [ __ ] yeah they're talking
[ __ ] and
the American public Falls for it and
even to this day you know in a realm of
video games and computer simulations and
Americans in general are really suffer
from a really hard case of technophilia
they love technology they think
technology solves all problems
and as the [ __ ] cop as a combat vet
from the Infantry and Airborne [ __ ]
units I'm telling you no
no the best weapons we had involved in
no technology just caveman dumb [ __ ]
because if you build these [ __ ]
technological [ __ ] monstrosities and
you get them out on a battlefield and
the [ __ ] temperature drops to 40
degrees below zero for [ __ ] months
and none of that [ __ ] works you know
[ __ ] none of these high-tech plans
ever [ __ ] survive contact with
reality and nature you know just [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] up we didn't want any
Optics we didn't even like night vision
it just didn't work and and it was an
unpre impractical to something that
they're forcing on you you know here put
these goggles on yeah they work under
certain conditions but like I said
[ __ ] 30 degrees below zero none of
that [ __ ] worked battery's [ __ ] gone
and
doesn't matter you know instincts worked
better it's the same with this
technological fantasies I'm gonna build
this high-tech weapon and blow up the
little kids nah it doesn't work that way
you're gonna have to stand up there with
a [ __ ] homemade Cannon and set it off
that's
the way an army would do it you know
he's full of [ __ ] but this is a fantasy
prone person
yeah like I said Eck was the same
there's there's a particular subset of
serial killers that are all like this
personality type and he's definitely
yeah he's fantasy prone he's fantasizing
yeah
um yeah so the day after that letter uh
which was October 20th somebody claiming
to be the Zodiac
um called the Oakland Police Department
and wanted either Melvin belli or F Lee
Bailey who were both very well-known
attorneys in the area uh wanted at least
one of them to appear on the next
morning's TV pro broadcast of like kind
of the popular like uh Morning Show the
am San Francisco uh Melvin Bell I said
he would do it and so he comes on the
show and a caller called in identifying
himself as zodiac also as Sam and he
said I'm gonna meet you like in Daly
City at a specific time like they were
supposed to meet up like in person like
I'll show you who I am and [ __ ] like
that Melvin Bell I went there but of
course like nobody ever showed up so
again that was like more piece of crap
so about three weeks after that the San
Francisco Chronicle gets another little
package now this one was postmarked
November 8th and it had a greeting card
in it that had like a picture like a
drawing of like a fountain pen that
looked like it was dripping blood and
then there was another note in it
um that had the Crosshair symbol and
there was like a notation on it that
said Des July August September October
equals seven uh which police maybe
thought that that could be referring to
maybe some like murders that he had done
that they didn't know about yet and then
there was another cryptogram uh
containing 340 letters and symbols now
this code was uncracked for more than 50
years but in 2020 uh three guys had been
working on it for a really long time
actually finally did solve it and this
was confirmed by the FBI
uh they call it the z340 code or Cipher
or whatever and uh again it says just a
bunch of [ __ ] the cipher reads I
hope you're having lots of fan in trying
to catch me like is it the [ __ ]
spelling
just like really sloppy with the code
you know what I mean uh I hope you're
having lots of fan and trying to catch
me that wasn't me on the TV show I guess
he means like the the TV show like the
caller which bringo up a point about me
I am not afraid of the gas chamber
because it will send me to paradise
d-i-c-e all the sue her because e now
have enough slaves to work I guess that
means work for me where everyone else
has nothing when they reach Paradise
with a c again so they are afraid of
death I am not afraid because I know
that my new life is life will be an easy
one in Paradise death
which okay whatever man that's like I I
don't even know he's got enough uh in
Paradise with a c like yeah he does like
I said [ __ ] can't spell he's Highly
Educated
he's a Rhodes Scholar
okay yeah yeah he's he's [ __ ]
tripping he's super smart
so yeah but they have finally saw that
would say it's like Edge Lord action I
know I can't believe that it took 50
years and it's like that was all that it
said I'm like man what a letdown if I
was the one that solved that code I'd
have been like
yeah it's like I really spent my whole
like the last however many years it took
them to like for that [ __ ] it's like
like I said that's why I don't know how
much I don't think there's that much of
his [ __ ] left to like decipher but I'm
just like don't even bother like I know
it's a challenge and stuff but it's just
gonna say more stupid crap like that
it's like not even worth but it's not
even worth the effort uh so yeah so the
day after that
uh the newspaper got this very rambling
like seven Page Letter which was
postmarked November 9th and in that one
the Zodiac claimed to have killed seven
people and also said something about
being angry about the lies police have
been telling about him and then he said
that he wasn't going to announce his
murders like ahead of time anymore he's
or that he wasn't gonna like tell them
like or take credit for them he was
actually going to disguise them as
robberies and accidents like he said
that kind of stuff
um and again he went on to say that the
police sketches only look like me when I
do my thing the rest of the time I look
entirely different yeah you'll never
find me that's a shape shifter yeah yeah
he's a shape-shifter yeah I'm like in
other words this note that tells me he
looked exactly like those [ __ ] well
of course
he's like what that means he's like
trying to throw people off the course
with like the dumbest [ __ ] possible it's
like it's it's it's one step above hey
look over there right you know you know
what I mean but he thinks he's like
super intelligent which is like
hilarious so I'm telling you he looks
exactly like those drawings
uh also in this little package was a
pretty detailed instructions and a kind
of little diagram for making a bomb
uh so then after that they didn't get
anything uh else from the Zodiac for
about a month
and then there was a letter and it was
actually addressed to Melvin Bella like
the lawyer and it was postmarked
December 20th and it came to the lawyers
uh you know post box or whatever so he
got a little bit before Christmas on the
outside of the envelope um the killer
wrote Mary X Mass m-a-s-s uh and New
Year and uh there was a little message
inside and basically asked Melvin bellai
to help him before he killed his ninth
and tenth victims I'm like wait a minute
didn't like the last one he said he
killed seven what happened to the eighth
one he's tripping
um so basically Zodiac's like I can't um
stay in control much longer uh you know
you have to help me before I kill again
blah blah like that kind of stuff and
then signed it with this little
Crosshair
so there actually wouldn't be another
murder that was maybe tentatively
attributed to him until you know the
next year but he did like send a lot
more like um [ __ ] letters and stuff
like that which we'll get into in a
minute now at this point I want to do a
little bit of an interlude and talk
about some possible victims these are
outside of the canonical victims but
several people have speculated that
maybe these people like uh were killed
by the Zodiac as well now this one this
is one that you don't hear a lot about
but there's a woman named Christy
Hawthorne and she was a historian in
that area and she thinks that the Zodiac
might have killed another cab driver
named Ray Davis in April of 1962. so
this is like six years before like his
first canonical murder uh and that was
an Oceanside
because
um on April 9th of 1962 like the day
before
um the guy got killed there the person
that they think eventually like killed
him called the Oceanside police
department and said I'm gonna pull
something here in Oceanside and you'll
never be able to figure it out
and then a couple days like after the
murder took place the cops got another
call from somebody that they thought was
maybe the same guy
um and he told the cops like details of
the murder and said I'm gonna kill a bus
driver next
um so basically I don't know like I kind
of feel like this is still an open case
like Oceanside police are still kind of
like looking into it saying maybe this
is the same guy like they did the Zodiac
kill killings later on which would tie
in with like the whole Palestine thing
which happened much later
also um this is one that I actually
wrote about my book there was a 1963 uh
murder of a couple in Northern Santa
Barbara County and this might have been
an early uh Zodiac Killer crime too this
actually happened on June 4th 1963 and
it was a high school senior named Robert
Domingos and his fiance whose name was
Linda Edwards and they were on a beach
near Lompoc it was actually a senior
ditch day so you know that's the day in
high school when it's like everybody you
know skip school so they had skipped
school and gone to the beach uh and they
got shot what happened was they think
that the um attacker tried to tie them
up which like I said that sounds very
zodiac
um but then they like got free and they
tried to like run away and then the
killer shot him a bunch of times in the
back and the chest with a 22 caliber
weapon okay
um then the uh whoever it was like then
put their bodies in this little Shack
that was like nearby they killed him and
then tried yet and then tried to uh burn
the shack down but it but he didn't like
succeed in doing that so that sounds
yeah and this was 63 that was like five
years before yeah I'm gonna see it it
was before all that yeah like way before
five years before the first canonical
right but it seems it's still it's still
two it's a couple on a beach it's random
it was just like shooting at them at
random and you tied them up and it's a
22 it's not a nine millimeter
but it was before maybe he decided to
upgrade maybe he thought well 22 I think
he shot the first two uh 22. maybe he
eventually decided if that was him maybe
he decided 22 wasn't enough
so he goes up to a nine millimeter yeah
I mean could be yeah
so probably 102 is not enough
or or they'd be issuing it to people I
love 22s [ __ ] I had some really good
ones like I love that little French mab
pistol from the 60s that was actually
60s or 70s my dad gave me back in the
day but I was had it in uh in the 90s
early 90s late 80s and that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] sweet
but that's not enough
um it's
only lucky hits [ __ ] cause anything
cause anything to happen the magic
doesn't happen with 22 unless it's a
[ __ ] lucky hit now if it's out of a
[ __ ] rifle barrel
uh there's a little more you're working
with a little bit more
um but no you don't really wanna
go into uh Harm's Way knowingly with
something like a 22. if you're gonna go
into a gunfight you take a [ __ ]
pistol you're just wrong all right you
go to a gunfight with an assault rifle
or a Belfair machine gun
you don't go with a pistol pistols are
emergency
things
and that's what you use to run away with
to run away to get to a rifle
[Laughter]
but the reason why
um people do use them
like the way police reason why Police
use them and the reason why
Intel agents or [ __ ] bad guys or even
Good Guys defending themselves whatever
is that they're concealable they're very
portable and you can hide it discreetly
that's what they're good at and in an
emergency you can defend yourself with
one
but if you're gonna go [ __ ] some people
up you don't take that you take a
[ __ ] assault rifle don't encourage me
I'm just saying that's that's why armies
carry them they don't issue pistols out
as a standard weapon
it's just a defensive thing
okay go ahead
all right so this is actually a case
that is often associated with the Zodiac
crime even though I'm pretty sure like
very recently they
um I don't know if they came out 100 but
maybe like 99 and said that this
probably was not the zodiac but this
happened on October 30th 1966. this was
an 18 year old student uh Riverside City
College named Sherry Jo Bates and she
was at the campus uh Library until it
closed at about nine o'clock P.M
and then neighbors reported hearing a
scream about an hour and a half later so
about 10 30. so they found Sherry Jo
Bates dead the next morning uh not too
far from the library between two
abandoned houses that were um going to
be demolished like they were doing
campus Renovations uh the wires in her
Volkswagen's distributor cap have been
pulled out so they assumed that somebody
did that and then waited for her to come
out and then was like oh we used your
car not working like I'm gonna help you
out like they figured that's what
happened uh she had actually been
horribly beaten and stabbed to death
they found a man's Timex watch with a
torn wristband uh found nearby the scene
the watch had actually stopped at 12 24
but they think the attack happened
earlier than that now a month after that
on November 29th 1966. it was a wind-up
watch
um I guess so yeah maybe just back in
the day they had wind-up watches yeah if
it came Unwound it would stop so that
might have been that maybe that's what
they were talking about yeah okay so
um a month after it happened they got uh
there was a bunch of typewritten letters
that were mailed to the Riverside Police
and also the Riverside Press Enterprise
like the newspaper for that area and the
letters were called the confession like
the same copy was sent to the both
places
so whoever wrote these letters claimed
responsibility for the Bates murder
um and put a bunch of details in there
that had not been released to the public
now in this letter
um it said bates's murder it's not the
first and she will not be the last
that's what it said
and then in December of 1966 uh somebody
found like a poem that was carved into
the bottom of a desktop like in the
Riverside City College Library
and it was called sick of living
unwilling to die
and the way that it was written like
reminded some people like of the way
that the Zodiac talks like in his later
letters and stuff let me say something
Amanda uh the shirt is actually
available uh me and Jenny make these if
you drop us a [ __ ] uh 20 something
dollar Super Chat I will send you one uh
just get your address later on but I'll
make you one and it'll be to you in a
couple days but uh I think she asked me
about the um the uh Ouija board one the
Ouija board one okay just whenever
you're ready send us some money through
a Super Chat and we'll we'll send you
shirts around twenty dollars plus
shipping for sure
yeah if you're gonna do a bulk one we
can work something out and as long as
you send me like later on like send me
your um like size and right your direct
mailing address and direct messenger
with the rest of the [ __ ] and we'll send
it to you so this thing that was found
like carved underneath the desk had what
looks like the initials RH on it but
they're not entirely sure if that's what
what the letters are now six months
after uh Sherry geobates was killed
Sherry Joe bates's dad
um and as well as the Press Enterprise
and the Riverside Police all got again
copies of the same letter and these were
all hand written and it said
they said Bates had to die there will be
more and there was like a little
scribble at the bottom that kind of
looked like of the letter z
um and so basically
in 2021 though because I know that the
Sherry Joe Bates crime you know I don't
think they ever you know they never
caught the person that did it obviously
and it's all and it's always like
associated with the Zodiac crime but in
August of 2021 the Riverside Police
Department's uh Cold Case thing like
came out and said that and I had just I
just learned this I didn't even know
this like on the last show that we did
they came out and said we found the guy
that wrote those letters
um they actually uh the guy anonymously
contacted them back in 2016 and and
admitted that it was him
um he wasn't the one that killed Sherry
Jo Bates though it was just like a joke
which is [ __ ] up
um but he said he was like a really
troubled kid he was a teenager at the
time and he came forward and said yeah
that was me and I'm really and I feel
really bad about it and I'm really sorry
um and he's was just trying to get
attention so I guess that they
investigated him over the next few years
and they determined not only that he had
indeed written the letters uh because
his fingerprints matched and everything
like that but they also determined that
he had not killed Sherry Jo Bates so
they still don't know who killed Jerry
Jo Bates but they know that it wasn't
the same person that wrote those letters
because now they know who wrote the
letters and it was just a hoax so
there's that
and I actually didn't know that until
today
so another crime that often gets brought
up in conjunction with the Zodiac case
is that of Donald lass now she was a
nurse at the Sahara Tahoe hotel and
casino uh she worked this was September
6 1970. she worked till about 2 A.M uh
they said her last patient was in there
about 1 40 A.M now later that same day
like after she went home
um Donna lass's boss and her landlord
got phone calls from an unknown man
pretty much saying Oh Donna left town
because she had a family emergency this
was not the case
Donna lass has never been found
now what appeared to be a grave site was
found near this Lodge like in Northern
California which is like Sierra Club
property uh but no evidence has ever
been uncovered to definitively connect
this disappearance with the Zodiac
Killer but because one of his letters
later on seemed to take credit for it
like it often gets Associated but she
hasn't been found like they've never
found her body she sounds like she
disappears how much I bet she was
missing he knew she was missing human I
did well see that's the thing I kind of
like like I said it is bad enough that
serial killers actually do kill people I
don't mean to like you know kind of
downplay that but a lot of times to make
themselves seem like bigger badder more
Edge lordy you know they'll take credit
for on other unsolved crimes that they
didn't do because it like it's free yeah
it's free it inflates their tally and it
makes them feel like you know oh I'm a
big man I killed way more people even
this zodiac said that he killed 37
people I don't believe that even Albert
Fish who was a perverted [ __ ] we
know he was [ __ ] perverted and did
all kinds of weird [ __ ] I'm pretty sure
he made up a lot of the stories that he
talked about
like you know
beating and raping and eating little
black boys and nobody knew I I don't
think so I I think I I think we pretty
much know who he killed
I think yeah I mean it's just it's
harder to say like from back from that
long ago because yeah there could have
been some crimes that you know they
didn't know about me he was maximum Edge
Lord and he likes to suffer and he loved
to suffer he'd hurt himself and he would
like to make himself be real repulsive
so the best way to do that yeah he got
off so he got off on that to to make
people real repulsed
so once you once your crimes are kind of
exposed
the repulsion has happened
well you're captured you can't do
anymore but you can't lie oh yeah I also
did this other stuff and I did this but
the [ __ ] is so over the top
it sounds like literature I think
they're trying like once especially once
they get caught or once they get into
prison well it was just kind of like we
did a whole show about [ __ ] Henry Lee
Lucas yeah who that [ __ ] was
nothing like what he said he was who I'm
sure killed at least two or three people
but what did he claim he killed like 60
[ __ ] people like he would he would
take credit for any [ __ ] yeah and he
didn't go he didn't do that [ __ ] and
would make up all kinds of Lura details
I'm not saying that he's a good person
because he did for sure like kill at
least two or three people yeah but all
of the people that I don't think he
killed any of the other people that he
said he killed oh you have to wrap your
mind around the idea that these guys
this is a basically a sexual them
outrage outraging you and repulsing you
is part of their sexual ident sexual
identity okay this is like a sexual
[ __ ]
alignment you know what I mean no what's
the word I'm looking for it's like a uh
what yeah this is their sexual
orientation
so they think that shit's sexy to
[ __ ] trip you out
so they'll lie to do it you know what I
mean they're not honest these aren't
honest people
so they just keep pouring it on oh yeah
and then I capture these four little
girls and then I did this to them and
but there's absolutely no evidence for a
lot of the [ __ ] that some of these guys
say well and sometimes some of their
fantasy life is so rich that some you
know maybe they're just like they wish
they did that you know well yeah yeah
they're they're telling a fantasy as if
they actually did it and they're trying
to see it see your reaction
that's what they're doing
um let me see hold on I'm gonna answer a
couple questions uh Crowley overheiser
says was the message card with a knife
or something else I'm assuming that it
was covered enough I'm assuming you mean
like uh in the desk I'm assuming that it
was carved with a knife yeah
um James staff said why you guys going
on this again is there another
development yeah there was actually um
we'll get to it at the end we're just
going over the case again I had totally
forgotten that we just did a Revisited
like a year ago yeah
um but there have been like some new
suspects and one of which I think is
like pretty uh compelling actually
Shauna says have you guys ever covered
the Texarkana Moonlight murders yes we
have uh we might have called it the
Phantom killer but it was a while back
not only have we talked about the actual
case the Texarkana Moonlight murders but
we also talked about that movie we also
did a review of that movie uh the town
that dreaded Sundown which was Loosely
based on those murders
um yeah Shauna said there's a lot of
younger people that haven't heard of
Jeffrey Dahmer until the Netflix special
started uh don't remember if you guys
covered him or not yeah I think we did
yeah we covered dumber and then fairly
recently I haven't watched the Netflix
show yet but I've heard it's like really
good I'll get around to it because I
love that kind of [ __ ] I watched
remember we watched the John John Wayne
Gacy one like not too long ago too yeah
he's a [ __ ] bag so all those dudes are
[ __ ] back well yeah of course I mean
that kind of goes without saying uh
James said you did call it the Phantom
killer it's real a real long time ago
like pre-100 worst one yeah Dean Coral I
[ __ ] can't stand Dean Coral man I'm
[ __ ] some of the [ __ ] that he did
they all kind of suck I mean it's really
kind of they're all they're all bad I
don't even like if you ask me right now
like who do I think is the worst one I
don't know I would have like a hard time
picking Decor the dudes from the toy box
killers are bad uh oh that was
[ __ ] oh let that [ __ ]
Leonard Lake yeah
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] Birds oh those two
were horrible [ __ ] [ __ ]
you see some of
I can't understand you know people's
aversion to the death penalty [ __ ]
you know uh they said well we're gonna
make them suffer this and that I I'm not
one for there are certain cases where
uh [ __ ] uh uh conventional punishment
[ __ ] would Escape Justice it's unjust
to lock these people up or to execute
them
the only Justice would be to do to them
what they did to others or worse you
know I mean
okay and I don't care what people say
say about that I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] what about your
versions of morality and what fairness
is I just want to get my hands on one of
those [ __ ] all right I'm gonna
do what I'm gonna do
[ __ ] Lake and [ __ ] Charles Nang
and [ __ ] coral and [ __ ] no no it's
unjust anything anything an organized
system could do to them
go look at what the Mexican cartels do
to people all right that's more what
they deserve if you ask me
[ __ ] and I got some dudes for I got
some [ __ ] from Mexico people videos
dudes from Mexico [ __ ] [ __ ] with
what's happening over there man [ __ ]
I'm like yeah some of these [ __ ]
serial killers need that done to them
they got IVs in them to keep them alive
and they're slowly cutting them apart
cutting their faces apart their tongues
out and the dude's alive for [ __ ]
hours they're talking to them just
disassembling him and [ __ ]
using medical technology to keep him
alive
[ __ ]
you can get even with a [ __ ]
you know
Straw Dogs 78 said will you ever cover
Ted Kaczynski I've been wanting to
actually I keep putting it in the poll
but it never wins
Ted Kaczynski was actually brought up um
as kind of like tangentially as like
maybe a suspect in the Zodiac Killer but
I'm pretty sure the FBI said no it
probably wasn't him very Vesuvius agrees
with me that's right lady there's some I
mean under under certain circumstances
like I said most people that are
probably on death row probably don't
like deserve it but um
yeah like the extreme case of like
serial killers like yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] like Ted Bundy and [ __ ]
like that it's like yeah I could see you
wanting to like do some horrible [ __ ] to
him because you know
they're kind of like not even and Amanda
Marie Serenity says The Dating Game
Killer I want to do a show about him too
Rodney uh Rodney Alcala I think they're
making either a documentary or they're
making a movie about him I was just
reading something about that the other
day that's some creepy ass [ __ ] too like
look that up on YouTube if you don't
know about The Dating Game Killer yeah
that guy was on The Dating Game just
like back in the 70s and he was a serial
killer like the whole time and the woman
picked him
and I think though that like when they
talk to each other I think she didn't
even go out on the date because she was
like she was like skeeved out by the
dude so like yeah she she like listened
to her gut probably he probably saved
her [ __ ] life
um yeah Phantom was episode 95.
yeah I knew it was a long time ago I
remember that was one of the first ones
that we did about uh Phantom killer or
you know Texarkana Moonlight murders
they call him that too
um Zach I think you already asked this
question on another show like which
serial killer do you find most
sympathetic
none of them that's what I mean none of
them really no no none of them really
like I said I kind of felt a little bit
bad for Jeffrey Dahmer but not no he was
not really I mean they're all they all
suck it's like I don't really nah he
drilled a hole in the [ __ ] teenage
kid's head and put Drano in there that's
what I mean it's just kind of like [ __ ]
no he deserved they all got [ __ ] he
deserved to be like Mexican cartel
[ __ ] vivisected [ __ ] taken apart
alive without an anesthesia over a
period of a few days being held together
with [ __ ]
saline [ __ ] pumps and [ __ ] blood
plasma and [ __ ] where they were taking
those dudes oh man you know I would have
[ __ ] him up
he was evil
and we don't live in a world of good
versus evil we live in a world of evil
versus evil but the best thing you can
do is evil versus evil to reduce the sum
total of evil for the benefit of the
general mankind all right and sometimes
you need some bad [ __ ] to happen to some
bad people all right that's actually
Justice I don't believe in the American
version of justice that that's that's
[ __ ] Justice
Amanda said I watched a documentary
about The Dating Game Killer and he
creeped me the hell out yeah he is
[ __ ] creepy like I said I've been
wanting to do a show about him for a
long time but like it never it never
wins in the poll
um ever thought about doing the doodler
um we did talk about the doodler but it
might not have been it was a long time
ago that was also probably pre 100. I
think we did a show with the doodler and
one other guy but I can't remember what
it was I'd have to like go and look but
I'm pretty sure we covered him before
Christopher Bell said off topic but
what's your opinion of Halloween ends I
haven't seen it yet and honestly I don't
know if I'm going to because it looks
like everybody hates it
um I like Halloween kills was okay but
I'm not usually one to like jump and go
see like the latest Halloween movie I
like the for I love the first one it's a
classic but you know the the sequels are
kind of just like hit or miss so it's
like I'll get around to seeing it but
there's like a bunch of other horror
movies that are still in the theaters
that I kind of want to see before I see
that one you know what I mean and like I
said pretty much everybody
that every horror Channel that I
subscribe to are just kind of like oh my
God it's like the worst beat like they
don't really like well I don't think
they thought the whole movie was a piece
of [ __ ] but like they really really
didn't like the way it ended
so I don't know I don't know but I'm not
really that worried about it uh crystal
said I saw it it's bad
I mean I'll probably wait until it's
free and then I'll watch it I'll watch
it when it's free I mean I will watch it
I'm curious but
it might be a while because I don't want
to pay for it
um all right so where was I okay so
we're talking about other
um
possible related crimes
so here's another one now this woman uh
thankfully didn't die
they still don't know if this is related
to the Zodiac case or not this is the
case of Kathleen Johns this happened
March 22nd 1970. now Kathleen Johns was
driving from San Bernardino to uh
Petaluma she was visiting her mom she
was actually seven months pregnant at
the time had her 10 month old daughter
in the car with her now she was uh
driving in the car and a car behind her
started honking its horn and like
flashing its headlights like something
was the matter with her vehicle so she
pulled off the road and stopped and the
dude in the car like gets out like comes
up to her car and says oh you're right
rear wheel is wobbling and um do you
know do you want me to tighten the lug
nuts for you and she's like yeah sure
whatever so he goes and does it and then
the man then he drove off and then she
started to drive off but then almost
immediately the wheel came off the car
because obviously yeah because obviously
he had taken the wheel off the car
because the dog nuts off the car so then
the dude comes back and says oh [ __ ]
look at that um I'll try drive you to
the nearest gas station for help
and apparently I don't know if they
actually like got in his car I guess
they like got in his car and he started
like driving them around I kind of feel
like if that had happened I'm not victim
blaming I'm just saying that if that had
happened to me well one I would not have
pulled over I'm just be like you can
flash your [ __ ] lights all day long
back there I'm not [ __ ] stopping but
um I don't know I I don't feel like
after that happened I think I'd be like
calling the cops because I'd be like
yeah this is dude I don't have cell
phones I know but it's just kind of like
what else I wouldn't like let this guy
oh this guy's gonna help you it's like
no he's not he just [ __ ] my car up but
yeah so there's that so they get in this
car and they're in there and like the
guy's driving and it passed like a whole
bunch of gas stations and she's like bro
um you know there was like we just
passed like 40 gas stations what the
[ __ ]
um and he didn't stop like every time
she was like why didn't you stop like
he'd always like change the subject so
he drove him around for like an hour and
a half and then drove like all these
back roads and [ __ ] and uh basically
then he stopped in an intersection and
she just like grabbed her down and
jumped the [ __ ] out the car which you
know that was probably the smartest
thing to do at that point and then she
ran out in the field and [ __ ] hid now
they're differing um I've heard
differing sources like one of the
sources said he never even got out of
the car he just like drove off and was
like [ __ ] it
um but some of the sources say that he
actually got out the car with a
flashlight and like went around in the
field like looking for her but didn't
find her like saying oh I'm not gonna
hurt you blah blah I'm like yeah I don't
believe that
um so after he drove off she actually
came out and like hitched a ride to the
nearest police station now while she was
giving uh-oh Pokey hey sweetie
she's like I can't stay up she's like I
can't stay up here I can't do this I
gotta be around down she's like you're
thwarting me yeah toys
during the whole show I don't know if
you can see her when she pops out she's
basically playing with her little toys
yeah she's got like all these she's got
little dogs little toys little mousies
and little mouse dollies
she's just like back there [ __ ]
around she likes to be with Mommy and
Daddy while we're kind of like
she'll grab a [ __ ] mouse mouse toy
and roll on her back stick her feet up
near
and grab another one and she have two
yeah she's funny she is she is a funny
little baby back there poke licking feet
Amanda said kisses for baby Pokey yeah
yeah oh yeah she's a sweetie but I like
that she hangs out back there she's like
really yeah she's talking to the lights
she's talking and we're talking to the
lights again yeah she's like why are you
not talking to Pokey yeah yeah
um but yeah so while Kathleen Johns is
in the police station and is giving her
statement to the sergeant that was on
duty she sees a composite sketch behind
him that was like hanging on the wall
this composite sketch was the suspect in
the killing of Paul Stein the cab driver
and she looks at that picture and she
says that's the guy that's the guy that
picked me up and you would think that he
would know because like she would know
because she drove around with this
[ __ ] for like an hour and a half
so you'd think that she'd know it was
the same dude
um so yeah so basically uh I don't know
so this guy like apparently threatened
to kill them but I don't know like
there's differing police reports on this
I'm not really sure
um if this is the same person or not but
the fact like I said that she drove
around he wasn't narrowed a mask or
anything like that and the fact that she
came in the police station and said hey
that looks like him I don't know that's
that's very suspicious to me but she
lived I mean her and her daughter were
okay but they weren't hurt or anything
so um so as I mentioned there actually
is no consensus on how many people the
Zodiac uh attacked or killed over the
years uh as I mentioned he claimed uh
various times to have killed 37 people
which I don't actually believe like I
said canonical is five but there's some
other ones that you know there's a lot
of evidence to think maybe he did that
too
um you know it just kind of feels like
I I've even seen some people say that
some of the Santa Rosa hitchhiker
murders which I don't did we do a show
about that
I can't remember if I because I remember
I wrote about it in my book but I don't
remember if we did a show about the
Santa Rosa hitchhiker murders because
there's like
that's the thing there's a lot of serial
killers going because you got Texas
Killing Fields which is probably
truckers but I think that's like at
least that's more than one person
um that's just like dumping bodies like
in the same area
but it's the same kind of thing I think
it's like a trucker type of thing it's
Santa Rosa hitchhiker murder is just
like picking people up and killing him
and some people have said too that some
of the Santa Rosa hitchhiker murders may
have been the Zodiac as well so I've
seen some other uh [ __ ] like that
um and basically I guess in the 80s
Robert graysmith the guy that wrote the
book that uh David Venture Zodiac movie
was based on he actually put out a list
of 49 uh confirmed and possible zodiac
targets like either people he'd killed
or like people they think maybe
suspicious and like some of the people
on that list are actually people that
are in the Santa Rosa hitchhiker murders
tally so I don't know I don't see like a
lot of evidence in that area but it's
not impossible you know what I mean
now um so and basically too that's the
thing I kind of feel like zodiac because
this is the last remaining high profile
unsolved serial killer case and that
it's so you know ingrained in American
culture that not only is there like a
new suspect pretty much every week but
every time there's kind of like a high
profile murder which is not solved
um they kind of say oh maybe the Zodiac
did it like if it's at all similar to
like some of the [ __ ] that zodiac did
like um now I don't know how
I don't even remember if we brought this
up because I know we did a show about
JonBenet Ramsey
um but some people have even posited
that the same person that did the Zodiac
crimes did the JonBenet Ramsey murder
too and that's mainly because of like
the whole Ransom note
situation
um because the ransom note also had
misspellings and like references to
Crime films and stuff like that just
like the Zodiac letters did uh because
you know like like I said the JonBenet
Ramsey one had like Dirty Harry [ __ ] in
there which like I said that sounds like
a very zodiac thing to do and Dirty
Harry was actually based on you know the
Zodiac case a little bit uh so there was
that so I don't know like 37 49 I I
don't know if I buy that it's not it's
not impossible it's not impossible but I
don't know
so that's the thing okay so he keeps
writing to
the papers and [ __ ] like that like over
uh 1970.
so uh his first letter of 1970 which was
postmarked April 20th
um zodiac again teased his identity with
like a 13 symbol Cipher which has not
been solved do I think it's going to be
his name no because none of the [ __ ] was
before but this one has not been solved
yet it's only 13 symbols
um he also in this particular letter he
said that he hadn't
participated in a bombing that had taken
place on February 18th
um in which a police officer like a
sergeant named Brian McDonald was killed
but he did again threaten to throw to uh
blow up a School Bus full of kids
and uh he had drawn like this little
diagram of his plans for the bomb
and in this letter he said that he had
killed 10 people that's what his tally
was at this point
his next letter was postmarked April
28th and this was a postcard and it had
like a cartoon of two Prospectors on it
one was riding on a donkey and the other
one was riding on a dragon and then the
printing on the front of the card said
sorry to hear your ass is a dragon
which well that's got to be one of the
worst puns ever yeah
um and then like next to the art like uh
he wrote hope you enjoy yourselves when
I have my blast which in big letters
which I'm assuming he meant like
referred to like the bomb he was
supposedly building
and then on the back of this postcard he
threatened again that he was going to
blow up a bus unless uh two particular
conditions were met these conditions
were one that his bomb threats be
published because you know he was all
about like the [ __ ] attention and two
that people in the San Francisco area
would start to wear zodiac buttons like
with the Crosshair symbol on them like
he wanted everybody to wear them he said
it would cheer cheer him up
like why the [ __ ] would anybody want to
do that no well he wants people to kneel
right to kneel and play pay respect
Lord yeah oh you see you wearing these
things yeah yeah no one's gonna do that
no it didn't work so yeah it did yeah so
two months go by uh and they don't hear
anything
so then a letter that's postmarked June
26 shows up at the San Francisco
Chronicle and uh in it he was very sad
that nobody had been wearing the Zodiac
buttons like I said what did you think
was gonna happen nobody's gonna do that
don't tell people what to do and uh said
hey I'm gonna blow up a school bus uh if
you don't do it and it's like he never
did that so you know
um but he said oh well I guess because
school is already out for the summer
because this was the end of June at this
point oh I instead I shot a man sitting
in a parked car with a 38 like instead
but they never did find a crime that you
know uh that matched that so again he
was like just bullshitting
also in this letter he had a map in
there and it supposedly showed the
location of a bomb that was set to go
off next fall that's all it said
and then at the end of the letter there
was another cryptogram which as far as I
know has not been solved either now they
looked in the location and of course
there was no bomb there and there was
again no crime that corresponded to the
shooting that he said that he did
now the next message that came was
postmarked July 24th uh again
complaining about nobody wearing the
buttons like I said what'd you think was
going to happen
um and it referred to and this is why
the whole Kathleen Johns thing
um is considered like a zodiac crime
because it specifically referred to her
in this letter what it said uh was I now
have a little list starting with the
woman and her baby that I gave a rather
interesting ride for a couple of hours
one evening a few months back that ended
in my burning her car where I found them
now the car was set on fire like when
they found it later
like she you know she got picked up by
the police and then like she went and
hid and then they found her car later
and it was like burning so
but that I mean that's vague enough that
he could have got the details from the
paper
um but he was taking credit for it like
obliquely
now they also there was another thing
that showed up like a couple days later
which was five pages
and he was threatening to torture the 13
slaves that uh the killer claimed were
waiting for him in Paradise again let's
see
um because people weren't wearing the
Zodiac buttons he was really really yeah
yeah into that idea of everybody wearing
the Zodiac buttons like he really wanted
to make everybody comply with his stupid
little wishes and he was like getting
mad when it wasn't happening and he was
making all these stupid threats that you
know he you knew he wasn't going to go
through with at this point you know what
I mean yep
so there's that oh and there's also and
this kind of like factors into some [ __ ]
later on too uh he also rewrote the
lyrics from a song from the very famous
Gilbert and Sullivan's Opera the Mikado
um and he kind of like changed the
lyrics to kind of go more along with his
little list thing like a people he was
gonna murder and [ __ ] like that uh he
referred to Gilbert and Sullivan
particularly the Mikado like lots of
times in some of his letters so it was
like I guess a particular favorite of
his
um and in at the end of this letter he
also said that the location that he'd
pointed out on the map in the June 26th
letter that was supposedly led to a bomb
which uh you know didn't it said he said
the quote was concerns radians plus
number of inches along the radians now
when they figured out what the [ __ ] this
meant uh it was discovered that the hint
on the map that he'd actually like
actually pointed to the sites of the two
previous like zodiac crimes so it wasn't
anything new he was just saying hey I'm
just it's neat that I'm coding like
where I already did the crimes
uh so then like they didn't hear from
him again for a little while
then they got another postcard from him
like the chronicle did and this was
postcard the postmarks October 5th now
this one didn't take any credit for any
murders which was unusual and was also
unusual in that it wasn't handwritten it
actually was just like a bunch of words
and letters that were like cut out from
other Publications
um and also the message didn't really
mean anything so I don't know if that
was actually from him or whatever but
they think that it was
now uh Halloween of 1970. the reporter
Paul Avery uh from the San Francisco
Chronicle who had actually written a
bunch of uh articles about the case he
got
um a like little message of his own
so this was postmarked October 27th and
was addressed to Paul averly so it
spelled his last name wrong and it came
inside an envelope that had uh sorry no
Cipher written like twice it was written
in two lines but like twice like that
like it was an X configuration now the
card inside of it had a like a white
cartoon skeleton on it on a black
background and then the printed text on
the front said from your secret pal I
Feel It In My Bones you ache to know my
name and so I'll clue you in but then
the inside said but then why spoil the
game Happy Halloween and then the Zodiac
inside wrote boo then wrote peek-a-boo
you are doomed and the word 14 which
presumably meant that he had now at this
point killed 14 people like I said I
think at this stage he's probably like
adding [ __ ] on you know what I mean
um so on the blank side of the card
zodiac also wrote the words slaves and
Paradise again in an X configuration and
again Paradise is spelled wrong because
the [ __ ] don't know how to spell
it uh and then he figure out how to
spell Jesus Christ
um and then he wrote the phrases by fire
by knife by gun by rope he wrote them
all like vertically like on the back of
the card like so so [ __ ] Edge lordy
oh my God
uh so after that he goes quiet for about
four months
then uh March 13th uh the LA Times got a
short letter from him
and basically it said uh it was
basically taunting the police for not
being able to catch him uh referring to
the police as blue meanies which is also
spelled wrong because he spelled it with
two n's and yeah I know I mean his
spelling is atrocious and I'm a Grammar
Nazis like that really really bothers me
like I said it's bad enough to use a
serial killer but it's like every single
like uh he can't spell
and particularly because [ __ ]
like this like think they're so smart
and everything like that I'm like dude
you can't [ __ ] you can't even [ __ ]
spell it's like I've seen five-year-olds
could spell better than that come on
um but he tells the cops they had best
get off their fat asses and do something
so you know
also at this point in this letter he
also seemed to take credit maybe for
murdering Sherry Jo Bates which like I
said they're pretty sure that he didn't
do that [ __ ]
um he didn't name her specifically but
he did say in this letter he called it
my Riverside activity which they thought
was maybe talking about Riverside
Community College where she had been
murdered
and then he said oh you guys are only
finding the easy ones uh there's a hell
of a lot more down there like I said I
know they have to take that seriously
because maybe there's some murders that
he did that they don't know about but I
think a lot of it I think a lot of it is
bullshitting
uh he said that he was writing to the
times now because they don't bury me on
the back pages like some of the others
says zodiac was a cop uh no no not at
all he does he doesn't show he doesn't
show the skills or the [ __ ] no no
he's he he's uh of a lower social order
um somebody said well he must have been
military if he was military he was
something something [ __ ] out of the
Navy Maybe
um you know
no I don't think he was he's a wannabe
more than anything else
yeah I mean like I said this kind of the
personality type strikes me as similar
to like BTK yeah it was like not wanted
to be a cop he wanted to be a cop or
wanted to be a military like he idolized
that kind of like thing but it's like he
couldn't cut it you know or he just
didn't get into it yeah
you know
uh okay so about a week after that the
reason why I said that maybe Navy he
used some nautical symbols every now and
then in ciphers
and he did know how to tie knots
that doesn't mean much
I mean anybody can learn to tie knots
but they were they were knots that you'd
mostly like learn yeah I get that but
I'm just saying that anybody and
especially nowadays yeah and if a dude
was a real wannabe yeah I learned how to
tie a bunch of Girl Scouts right yeah so
it might have been something he learned
in the Boy Scouts so you don't know
that's what I'm just saying and I was
just in the Girl Scouts for like a year
and I learned how to tie a whole bunch
of knots I don't remember how to do it
now because that was a long time ago but
uh Danny Rowling said William McDuff
Andrew yeah we're going to talk about
him later uh looks a hell of a lot like
the sketch in the eye region he does
um I'm not so sure though but like I
don't know if you've heard of the other
guy but I'm going to talk about that guy
too uh have you done a show about Fritz
hunka I no we haven't I know for sure we
haven't done that but that's another one
that we need to get to
uh so about a week after that Paul Avery
uh the San Francisco Chronicle got
another zodiac postcard again had his
last name misspelled as averly the
postcard uh was postmarked March 22nd
and it was this pasted on photo that was
taken for an ad from uh for the Forest
Pines Condominiums and over this he had
glued like a bunch of phrases that had
been cut out of magazines uh these
phrases included Sierra Club around in
the snow peek through the pines and pass
Lake Tahoe areas
and then the big phrase at the bottom
said sought victim 12.
now uh taken in aggregate investigators
thought this card might have been very
obliquely claiming responsibility for
The Disappearance of Donna lass uh
because there was a lot of stuff in
there that kind of like referred to that
disappearance like she uh disappeared
from the Lake Tahoe area so they thought
maybe he was taking responsibility for
that
now after that
um the Zodiac actually went quiet for
almost three years
now then there was another letter that
came in it was supposedly from the
Zodiac and they got it actually a way
across the country this was at the
Albany Times Union in New York New York
State
this one was postmarked August 1st 1973.
now this letter is of questionable
provenance uh not only because it turned
out it was more than two years like I
said um after the Pines postcard which
they're pretty sure was zodiac
um but also because it was you know 3000
miles away like Waker on the other side
of the country not saying that the
[ __ ] couldn't move I mean it had
been several years
so the letter said you were wrong I am
not dead or in the hospital I am alive
and well and I'm going to start killing
again that's what it said uh the letter
specifically threatened to kill someone
at 5 pm on August 10th when the shift
change that's what it said which is
obviously grammatically incorrect
so then it said Albany is a nice Town
um and there was also a three-line
cryptogram at the bottom of the page but
this one was like pretty easily figured
out by the FBI like immediately
um and basically it said that the killer
would take a victim from the Albany
Medical Center and it said this is only
the beginning
now uh no murder actually took place at
the uh you know time and place that was
put in the letter and no crimes have
actually taken place that uh matched
that so a lot of people think that maybe
this was just like a hoax uh they call
it the Albany letter now interestingly
though there was a double murder that
happened in Los Angeles in 1969 that
might have some link with this and this
was a double murder of um a woman named
Dorian Gaul and a man named James Sharp
now after the murder they found a letter
in Dorian gaul's stuff
and the letter read so you think you can
fool the old killer haha I know all your
movements and the time they are made
time is short enjoy life while you can
you are too beautiful to live and I must
kill you the Zodiac Killer like they
found that in her [ __ ] like after she
died
now Doreen Gaul even though she was
killed in Los Angeles was originally
from Albany and where like where her
parents lived was really near the Albany
Medical Center which is where this
letter said that they were going to take
a victim from now her and James were
both found in Los Angeles like in a
[ __ ] alley on November 21st of 1969
they'd been stabbed more than 50 times
each and had their eyes like slashed out
so you know there's that
um so as I said though I kind of feel
like most zodiac researchers think maybe
the Albany letter was somebody else like
maybe it was a hoax or something like
that but you know no one really knows
for sure
so January 29th 1974. uh another letter
shows up at the San Francisco Chronicle
this is known as The Exorcist letter
because in it uh whoever wrote it refers
to the Exorcist as the best satirical
comedy that I have ever seen also makes
another reference to uh Gilbert and
Sullivan's the Mikado like changing the
lyrics and stuff and said uh if you
don't publish this note in the paper I'm
gonna do quote unquote something nasty
and uh this is the point where he said
that he'd killed 37 people he's like me
37 sfpd zero that he said that in there
um so this there was another message
that came in like two weeks later
but from this point forward they think
like the authorship of the letters is
largely disputed so it's possible that
the Exorcist letter was the last genuine
message because they think that one was
actually sent by the actual zodiac but
the ones after that they're not entirely
sure but there were more after that so
Valentine's Day there was a postcard uh
that showed up at the San Francisco
Chronicle this one had the message on it
dear Mr editor did you know that the
initials s l a y symbionese Liberation
Army spell slaw SLA an Old Norse word
meaning kill and then it signed a friend
so you know what I mean uh yeah uh so
then May 8th the Zodiac or some are
pretending to be him sent another letter
to the San Francisco Chronicle this time
complaining about a recent ad campaign
for a movie called Badlands and it was
basically said sirs I would like to
expression my consternation
concerning your poor taste and lack of
Sympathy for the public as evidenced by
your running of the ads for the movie
Badlands featuring The blurb in 1959
most people were killing time Kitt and
Holly were killing people in light of
recent events this kind of murder
glorification can only be deplorable at
best not that glorification of violence
was ever justifiable why don't you show
some concern for public sensibilities
and cut the ad now this one and it was
signed a citizen
I don't think this one was the Zodiac um
probably just because other than leg to
expression my consternation everything
was spelled correctly and was mostly
grammatically correct which doesn't
really seem like zodiac style you know
what I'm saying so I don't know if that
was really him yeah his illiterate ass
but yeah that seemed like a little too
grammatically correct to be him uh so
two months after the Badlands card uh
something else shows up in um the at the
San Francisco Chronicle this one is
postmarked July 8th 1974 and said editor
put Marco back in the hell hole from
whence it came he has a serious
psychological disorder always needs to
feel Superior I suggest you refer him to
a shrink meanwhile cancel the count
Marco column since the count can write
anonymously so can I and it was signed
the red phantom red with rage
uh this one the the Marco of the letter
that they're referring to is probably
referring to the chronicle columnist
whose name was Marco Spinelli who had
the name like count Marco that's what
they know him as and he was kind of like
a he was essentially like a troll like
back in the 70s like he would write
these crazy like a very controversial
like advice column he had a television
show he had books and he would give like
this really ridiculous and really like
frankly pretty misogynistic like advice
to women on how to behave like toward
their man like you know what I mean so
but he was like being outrageous on
purpose
um so that's who he was talking about
like this count Marco guy now if the
Zodiac did write this letter then it was
probably his last one I kind of doubt it
I think the Exorcist letter was probably
the last one that he that the actual
zodiac wrote but they're not really sure
um now there was another zodiac letter
that arrived at the chronicle in April
of 1978 and there was a greeting card
from 1990 that they found later on in
the like the back catalog of like the
newspapers files
um but neither of these has been
authenticated so they're not entirely
sure if those are uh zodiac or not so
now let's talk about let's get into
talking about the suspects because this
is kind of like the last thing that
we're going to get into is the suspects
because that's kind of like all the
letters and all the victims and
everything like that
so probably the best known uh suspect uh
which we probably talked about on the
last show was Arthur Lee Allen and like
I said I kind of feel like most people
probably think that he's still the main
suspect because of the David Fincher
movie which a lot of people have seen
now Arthur Arthur Lee Allen was actually
first interviewed by the police after he
was seen in the Lake Berryessa area at
around the time that um Brian Hartnell
and Cecilia Shepard were attacked that
was September of 1969. now uh Alan said
that he'd been scuba diving nearly 100
miles away when the crime occurred and
was subsequently released but in 1971
he uh was again like you know he got
brought to the attention of authorities
again when his friend whose name was Don
Cheney reported to police that Allen
told him like sometime in late 1968
early 1969 that he was planning on
killing couples at random and that he
was going to use the name zodiac so like
his friend apparently like knocked on
him that he said that
so there were like some other pieces of
circumstantial evidence that tied Alan
to the Zodiac case it wasn't just the
fact that his friend said that he was a
zodiac now he did have a zodiac brand
watch that had the Crosshair symbol on
it uh which a lot of people thought was
like kind of important Alan also wore a
size 10 and a half shoe and had been in
the Navy uh which meant that he could
have been responsible for making the
they found like size 10 and a half
military boot prints like at the lake
Berry ssite so they're like okay well he
could have made those
um he also said that on the day of the
uh the Hartnell Shepard attack he was he
had like a pair of bloody knives on his
person he said oh but I just used them
to slaughter a chicken which sounds a
little sus
um also Alan readily admitted that his
favorite story was the most dangerous
game which was a story which was
referenced uh at least once in uh some
of the uh zodiac ciphers and letters
like that was kind of like something
that he talked about all the time
also uh Alan lived in Vallejo California
uh during this period when the Zodiac
murders took place and where he lived
was very close to where Darlene Farren
lived uh she was one of the victims from
July 1967. now Michael Maggio who lived
through the attack in which Darlene was
killed actually did pick Alan out of a
photo lineup although that was several
years later I think it was in 1992.
now uh Allen's house was also only 15
minute uh 15-minute drive from the sites
of the Blue Rock Springs and Lake
Hermann attacks and the phone booth
where the Zodiac had reported the Blue
Rock Springs murder uh was only a
10-minute walk away from his house
now Arthur Lee Allen did get convicted
in 1974 of committing lewd acts on a 12
year old boy and spent the next two
years in prison after he got released uh
he was questioned several times by
detectives on the Zodiac case
so they searched his house in 1991 and
they found a Royal typewriter which was
very similar to the one which had been
used to produce the letter that had been
sent to Riverside Police Department in
like after Sherry Jo Bates was murdered
in 1966 but like I said because nowadays
they know that probably zodiac didn't do
Sherry Jo Bates that might not mean much
of anything
uh during the same search of their house
of his house in 1991 they also found a
bunch of diagrams that appeared to be
instructions for making bombs they also
um it's basically like they they found
some stuff that seemed like fishy but
nothing that definitively tied him to
any of the murders in particular and he
ended up dying in 1992 and no charges
relating to that case were ever filed
against him
so I don't know the the thing about it
like I said a lot of recent evidence
that's come out since then
um pretty much is like casting a lot of
a lot of Doubt on his guilt like his
fingerprints and his palm prints prints
didn't match any of the prints that they
uh got from the uh you know the Paul
Stein murder or any of the like the
letters or anything like that didn't
match also he didn't really look like uh
the composite sketch of the Killer and
although as I mentioned Michael Maggio
who survived the attack did actually
identify Allen as the man who had shot
him
um the identification was made several
years later it was like in 1992
um from a driver's license photograph so
he could have been mistaken like for
sure uh and definitively in 2002 uh the
San Francisco police department they got
a partial DNA profile from the saliva on
the stamps in the envelopes from
Zodiac's letters like the ones that they
know for sure was him they compared the
partial DNA to that of Arthur Lee Allen
and they also compared it to his friend
who it originally like said that oh hey
he said he was the Zodiac so they
checked both of those [ __ ] DNA
and neither of them matched so they
actually uh rolled both of them out
uh also the police handwriting expert uh
said that Arthur Lee hand Arthur Lee
Allen's handwriting didn't look anything
like the Zodiac's handwriting it's like
yeah it's possible he could have been
writing with his left hand or some [ __ ]
like that but when he writes normally
like it doesn't look anything like the
Zodiac's handwriting and handwriting
analysis is very you know iffy iffy but
they're like it just didn't look
anything like that
so some other suspects which we'll go
through very briefly and then we're
going to talk about like the two new
ones
so in 2018 uh there was an Italian
journalist named Francesco and McCone
and he actually said that he thought the
Zodiac Killer might be a guy named
Giuseppe Beval Aqua who was actually the
former superintendent of the Florence
American cemetery and Memorial and he
thought that he was the suspect in both
the Zodiac and the monster of Florence
murder cases we also did a show on the
monster of Florence not too long ago
which is a very famous like Italian
serial killer uh case
and uh but this guy bevel Aqua actually
testified at the trial of the Prime
Suspect for the monster of Florence case
whose name was Pietro uh pacciani that
was back in 1994.
um so basically
according to this journalist
um bevel Aqua confessed to being the
Zodiac and the monster of Florence in
2017. I don't know if they're still I
think they were like investigating that
up until maybe 2021 but I haven't heard
anything since then
so another guy uh that they were looking
at in 2009 there was an episode of a
History Channel TV series called mystery
quest and they were looking into this
newspaper editor named Richard
gaikovsky I think is how you pronounce
his last name now uh at the time that
the Zodiac murders were taking place
this guy worked for a thing called like
a newspaper called Good Times it was
like a counterculture type newspaper uh
he actually did look like the composite
sketch and um the recording that they
had of the voice of like the the guy
that had called and like took uh credit
for some of the murders like the
dispatcher said that that sounded like
his voice
incidentally
um Tom Voigt who is kind of like the
best known citizen researcher of the
case he's the guy that founded the
website zodiac killer.com which is like
a huge repository of zodiac information
if you ever want to go over there and
check it out uh he actually at this
point uh favors this guy as the killer
I'm not sure entirely why because it
doesn't seem like there's a huge amount
of evidence
um I don't know there's nothing really I
kind of feel like there's no real solid
evidence like tying into the case but
like I said it could be him you know
what I mean
um but one thing that I did see said
that whether or not like he was the
Zodiac or he did some of the crimes
um the date of the first confirmed
zodiac murders which was December 20th
1968 they're almost entirely sure that
this dude was out of the country on that
date uh so you know he probably couldn't
have done it
and I think we mentioned this before
like this guy keeps coming up all the
time but uh good old Steve Hodel who we
probably talked about on the Black
Dahlia show because he's the guy that
came forward and said that he thought
that his dad killed the Black Dahlia
which I don't maybe I I kind of maybe
buy that more than I buy this but I kind
of feel like he went Hog Wild with my
dad as a serial killer kind of issue and
then he's like well every unsolved
serial killer cries in the world like
it's my dad I kind of feel like that
became a thing like for a little while
so like I said and I'm I'm into like you
know the case that he laid out for his
dad being the Black Dahlia killer I was
like okay I can baby buy that I don't
know if it's true but it's like I could
buy that like it sounded you know it
sounded plausible but uh after a while
like he wrote another book and said um
that his dad was also by the way the
Zodiac Killer
um saying oh you know he looked like the
police sketch and it's like the
similarity of the zodiac Killers to like
the Black Dahlia Avenger letters blah
blah so it's like I don't know I kind of
feel like that's I'm not saying it's not
possible anything's possible but it
doesn't really sound all that plausible
to me
uh also there's another guy named
Lawrence K now this guy was apparently
the same guy I guess Kathleen John's the
one that like got away like her and her
daughter
um she actually picked him out of a
photo lineup like when they kind of
asked her to look at all of the [ __ ]
um and she basically said and also like
the guy that was the first responding
officer at the murder of Paul Stein the
cab driver that responding officer said
that Lawrence Kane looked like the guy
that him and the other officer had seen
like walking up the street like away
from the cab at this point now Lawrence
K or or Kane I've seen it both ways
um also allegedly worked at the same
Nevada hotel as Donna lass who
disappeared also Kane was diagnosed with
an impulse control disorder like after
he got like a brain injury like in an
accident in 1962
he had been arrested for prowling and
for voyeurism
and uh also there was some kind of thing
like one guy claimed that he had solved
the z13 cipher like the one that still
hasn't been solved it's like 13 symbols
and he said that the solution to the
puzzle reads my name is care k-a-y-r
which he's saying well that could be
like a typo because he did do a lot of
typos but I don't think that it's been
confirmed it's it hasn't been confirmed
that he solved that Cipher so he could
just be like talking out his ass but you
know so there's that anyway
uh there was also another case a guy
named Richard Marshall and that was a
guy that police informants uh accused of
being him uh saying that he had told
them that he was the murderer he
actually did live in Riverside in 1966
and in San Francisco in 1969 very close
to the scenes of the Sherry Joe Bates
and the Paul Stein murders he was also a
big silent film fan and a projectionist
and one of his favorite movies was the
red phantom from 1907 which was you know
turned up in one of the letters which
maybe or maybe not was written by the
Zodiac I don't really know like I said
that seems a little bit certain like not
even circumstantial that seems like a
little bit of a reach but okay
February 2018 uh there was another guy
uh put forward Louis Joseph Myers and
apparently he confessed to a friend of
his in 2001 that he was the Zodiac
Killer after he learned he was dying of
cirrhosis and said that his friend whose
name is Randy Kenny uh should go to the
police after he dies and like tell them
that I was the Zodiac so Myers died in
2002
um and Kenny did go to the police but
they didn't really like believe him like
they didn't take him seriously uh so
there are a couple of connections
between Myers and the Zodiac case uh he
did go to the same high school as uh
David Faraday and Betty Lou Johnson like
the first victims and he might have
worked in the same restaurant as Darlene
Farren also another one of the victims
also during 1971 and 1973 when no zodiac
letters were received by anybody Myers
was stationed overseas with the military
so they thought that was interesting
um also uh basically his friend said oh
well he started targeting couples
because he had had like a really bad
breakup with his girlfriend and it made
him mad and so he was like jealous so he
was going around like killing other
couples
um so you know they basically the cop
said uh to Kenny like hey if you can
come up with anything like more solid
than that then we'll like look into it
uh another guy Robert Ivan Nichols uh
AKA Joseph Newton Chandler III uh he was
actually an identity thief he committed
suicide in July of 2002. now after he
died uh the investigators couldn't find
his family and they actually found out
that he had stolen the identity of an
eight-year-old boy who was killed in a
car crash in Texas in 1945. because he
had gone to Such Great Lengths to hide
his true identity
um the FBI were thinking maybe this
[ __ ] had like some really bad
[ __ ] to hide so they started like
investigating him for something
so he does he did kind of look like
police sketches of the zodiac and he did
live in the area at the time period but
other than that I don't really know if
there's any other like solid evidence
like pointing to him
there's another guy named Ross Sullivan
how would Hayden your identity save you
from that case though that's that's a
little odd that's not how they're gonna
catch you you know what I mean yeah
they're gonna catch you through
fingerprints
and uh they're gonna catch you at the
scene I don't I don't think I don't
think that I don't think that has
anything to do with the case
guy had a fake ID for some reason
built on a yes I mean he's probably
running for something Financial more
than that yeah I mean there's millions
of reasons why you might it's not
necessarily that you're receiving in
fact it's probably not probably not a
serial killer I kind of feel like just
don't do that they generally don't I
kind of feel like it's it's a different
to me it seems I'm not saying it's
impossible but to me it seems like a
completely different kind of crime
usually like you said it's usually more
like Financial type of stuff like I've
embezzled like 40 million dollars right
or I'm taking loans out in this one or I
[ __ ] burned my other identity up
taking these [ __ ] loans out and [ __ ]
so I'm gonna be yeah it's usually that
usually something like that it's usually
it doesn't seem like the same
personality type that through those two
things I'm not saying it can't overlap
I'm sure it does everything it wouldn't
help it wouldn't help you evade serial
murder cases
uh cases it wouldn't you're evading
paperwork when you do that
not physical evidence yeah
because you know think about it how
would a fake ID save you from that right
it wouldn't
because they catch you they don't catch
you with through a paper trail they
catch you through things like DNA
fingerprints you being at the scene
[ __ ] witness testimony that's how
they catch you and [ __ ] you having a
[ __ ] a clean ID or a fake ID that
doesn't help you with that mission
no you make a new ID to run from
something in your past
usually Financial yeah I kind of feel
like whenever they find some
[ __ ] that does that it's almost
always they embezzled like a [ __ ] yeah
took out a bunch of loans on houses and
[ __ ] sold them without ever [ __ ]
paying the money or those [ __ ]
that always kind of like go and marry a
woman yeah and then take all her money
and then like change their identity and
go marry another one you know what I
mean it's that kind of stuff right that
kind of [ __ ] not so much serial killer
right
I mean not that they're not organized
but yeah but if one did that it's like
you wouldn't catch him so no if a serial
killer did that no you'd still catch him
no I'm just saying that it would be
rarer that you would catch himself if
you had a serial killer doing that
because they catch you through physical
evidence not Paper Trails yeah so it
wouldn't matter what you said your
identity was
they could take your fingerprints and
Max it to those fingerprints that they
got from that crime scene and that's it
it's a wrap or they arrested you fleeing
from the scene of that crime they don't
care what your name is they got you you
know [ __ ] it's that kind of stuff
yeah I mean unless aren't focusing on
that you can't like [ __ ] change your
DNA yeah yeah right sure kids aren't
focusing on that you can always file off
your [ __ ] or cut off your
fingerprints but still they're mostly
catching you at the scene or you're
associated with the victim or you're the
DNA Left Behind it's just it's not it's
not the
changing your identity does not help you
from it does not help mask serial
killing it masks financial [ __ ] that
you've done that's what they're doing
when they do that usually American
Military 100 says cool 13 o'clock
revisits the Zodiac re-revisits the
Zodiac yeah like I said this is the
third time and they're not drunk yet
either yeah yeah we're not like
amazingly we're getting towards the end
of it aren't we well it's more or less
okay because I got cooking I got I mean
don't rush me all right don't rush me
look I told you I mean
don't start I'm gonna get some pizza
going don't start yeah I said gonna
listen to this start to finish yeah I
mean we covered the whole case again but
we're getting into the like new [ __ ] now
all right so uh another guy is a guy
named Ross Sullivan and uh he actually
came to the attention of police through
his association with Sherry Jo Bates uh
he was actually a library assistant at
Riverside City College like where she
was killed and was suspected by
co-workers because apparently he went
missing for a few days after the murder
but like I said because they pretty much
established with 99 certainty that the
Zodiac did not kill Sherry Jo Bates it's
possible that this [ __ ] did kill
her but was still not the Zodiac you
know what I mean he did actually kind of
I will say though he does actually kind
of look like sketches of the zodiac
although a lot of people do and uh he
did wear military style boots with
Footprints like those that were found at
Lake Berryessa uh he was also
hospitalized a bunch of times for
schizophrenia bipolar disorder stuff
like that so he had some mental issues
as well
uh in 2007 a guy named Dennis Kaufman uh
claimed again more relatives doing the
[ __ ] uh he claimed that his stepfather
Jack Terence not Jack Torrance uh was
the Zodiac uh he actually turned a bunch
of items over to the FBI including a
hood similar to one worn by the Zodiac
um but they they did some DNA evidence
on the hood and everything like that but
it was inconclusive I believe they did
that in 2010 and I haven't heard
anything about that particular guy since
then 2014 a guy named Gary Stewart
published a book called the most
dangerous animal of all which was uh
from one of Zodiac's letters and he said
that his uh biological father Earl Van
Bess Jr uh he thought he was the Zodiac
Killer and they actually in 2020 they
adapted this book for uh FX Network as
like a documentary series which I have
not seen so I'll have to kind of like
look into that a little bit too but I
don't know you know like I said this I
haven't really heard much about that
particular thing all right so let's talk
about
Gary France's post because we did talk
about him in the last revisit because
that had just happened uh that happened
back in I believe September or October
of 2021.
so what ended up happening so back in
October 2021 uh you know kind of
everybody like every media Outlet in the
[ __ ] world came and said oh my god
um they've identified the Zodiac Killer
like it was a big [ __ ] deal
now what it was there was like a bunch
of it wasn't law enforcement it was a
bunch of kind of like former detectives
like former cops former investigators
stuff like that and they'd kind of like
put together this little citizen
investigation group I think there was 40
of them and they called themselves the
case Breakers
and they had been like trying to solve
this case and they came forward like in
a press release and said we figured out
who it was it was this guy named Gary
Francis post uh who had actually died in
2018. now he had lived in Groveland
California he died like I said in 2018
he was 80 years old and he had worked
for a painting companies like a house
painter and he'd worked for like 40
years and he was married like his wife's
name was Mary
so uh they said that
what okay so what they thought like this
guy's like the evidence was behind this
apparently he had the guns that he had
done the murders with like he had buried
them like out at this remote location
and so they're wanting the FBI or
whatever to like go out and find the
weapons and that they'll be able to get
like ballistics off that and like
fingerprints and DNA and stuff like that
they think they've also uh come up with
a bunch of other murders that can be
attributed to him like based on you know
various signatures and like details
around the cases
there's also and this is a lot less
credible because I just saw this report
in like the [ __ ] tabloids and stuff
but a guy came forward he was like in
his 50s and he said that post when he
was younger like had groomed him and
turned him into a killing machine and
that post had like a whole like group of
boys that he called the Posse that he
like trained to be Killers essentially
which like I said sounds far-fetched I'm
gonna say it's not impossible
yeah but
it wasn't not it's not the same thing as
like what this guy is yeah and the fact
that it was only published in like
[ __ ] really like really like shitty
tabloids it's like that I don't know
they don't really have like a lot of
it's one guy that came forward and was
making up this Phantom I'm not saying
that it can't happen like weirder [ __ ]
has happened but it just sounds a little
far-fetched to me it just sounds
far-fetched
um also the case breaker said that there
were photographs from post's dark room
uh that there was a picture of him in
there of of him like wearing the Zodiac
Hood
um but as far as I know they have not
been able to produce that they also said
that if you take out the letters of his
name from one of the ciphers then the
cryptogram like gives you an alternate
message but they won't tell anybody what
that is for some reason so you know also
one of the big things that they kept
pointing out was that oh there's a bunch
of scars on post's forehead and these
are similar to the scars which are in
the police sketches of the zodiac but
see I never saw I never thought like the
very famous like um you know iconic
sketch of the zodiac I never thought
those were scars I just thought they
were like forehead wrinkles and I kind
of feel like that's what most people
thought they were I didn't think they
were scars on their head you would think
that if you had scars on his forehead
that would be like a big thing that the
victim like surviving victims would say
oh he had scars on his forehead I kind
of feel like he just looked like he was
like squinting or like snarling and like
he had like lines on his fore like
wrinkles you know I thought it was that
so I don't know about this whole
scarring thing but apparently like post
did have scars on his forehead and they
said oh it looks just like the drawing
but I don't I don't know if I'd buy that
now uh February 22nd of 2016 post
actually was arrested and accused of
assaulting his wife Mary uh in their
house and he was all like an old man at
this point
uh so he got charged uh with corporal
injury to a spouse and uh another charge
of like Elder and dependent adult abuse
and then he got
um found mentally incompetent to stand
trial and got referred to like a state
hospital and was put under like mental
health conservatorship because like I
said he was like a very elderly at this
point
um so basically I don't know the thing
about it is I think the case Breakers
most of their evidence comes from the
Sherry Joe Bates crime scene
like you know they're why they pause it
that post is the Zodiac problem with
that with that though is that nowadays
like the Riverside Police Department
have pretty much come out and said 99
100 the Zodiac did not kill Sherry Joe
Bates they don't know who killed Sherry
Jo Bates but they're pretty sure almost
entirely sure that it was not the Zodiac
so if you're going to pause it if all of
your evidence is coming from the Sherry
Jovi so I'm not saying that this guy
didn't kill Sherry Jo Bates he very well
might have but
they're kind of like pretty sure that
those are two completely different
people like the person that killed
Cherry Jo Bates and the person that was
the Zodiac are not the same person so if
all of your evidence coming from comes
from the Sherry Joe Bates case
um then that person is probably most
likely not the Zodiac so I kind of feel
like that's where most of their stuff
was coming from
um you know and like I said a lot of the
letters that they kind of like leaned
hard like the case Breakers kind of
leaned hard on like these letters about
uh you know the Sherry Jo Bates case
like all the letters that came from like
1966 those letters were a hoax they've
pretty much determined that they know
the guy that did it that guy was not the
killer uh he wasn't the Zodiac and he
wasn't the person that killed Cherry J
baits either so again that I kind of
feel like their case has fallen apart a
little bit so there's that
um gonna say too that Tom Voight the guy
who's followed this case for a quarter
century and run zodiac killer.com as I
mentioned earlier uh he described the
claims about Gary post as hot garbage uh
and really didn't understand why anybody
because like I said what didn't come
from law enforcement it came from
casebreakers which is like a citizen
sleuth group and it was just a press
release everybody like flipped out about
it but some people were like really sit
really cynical about it they're like
look if you want like media attention
clearly all you have to do is come
forward and say hey we solved this big
like unsolved like Cold Case that's been
going on forever and you know just watch
the [ __ ] clicks roll in and I kind of
feel like that's maybe what happened
with that so you know all right so let's
talk about William McDuff Andrew
AKA Mac uh this guy I just saw like a
video about him like literally like 20
minutes before we did the show uh so
this guy I don't know how much he does
look like the sketch like he is kind of
like a chubby guy he had glasses like he
looks like you know the the iconic
sketch for sure but like I said a lot of
people do now he was actually from the
Vallejo area uh the lake Herman Road
Site was only about seven miles from his
parents house the phone booth that the
call came from after the Blue Rock
Springs attack was only 500 feet from
his parents house uh as I said he did
resemble uh Michael mejo's description
he was 24 years old at the time of that
uh crime he was five foot eight about
200 pounds uh kind of chubby large round
face uh and glasses he um there was also
kind of like a link with the uh killing
of Officer Richard ratatich who was
actually uh killed in June uh June 26
1970 who was gunned down in San
Francisco and uh actually October of
1971 showed Mac living right around
there like less than a quarter mile from
where he was killed I kind of what we
got a good ass chat look at all those
people in the chat I know well how many
people are there they're 50 something in
there we'll see if that's good see it
was good we did another very good we did
another again pretty good it's pretty
big check go ahead and hit us up with
some super chats people you know how I'm
gonna [ __ ] try to flip you over for
some of that money go ahead all right
thank you very much Ben said I read a
book called the most dangerous animal
yeah I was just talking about that
earlier from some nut who was convinced
his dad was a zodiac really I kind of
feel like that was I Steve Hodel started
that [ __ ] oh you know what time it is
Jenny what it's time for a [ __ ]
commercial I don't have any questions no
all right I had a million other things
yeah I forgot about it all right I don't
have any commercials loaded watch just
let me know let me finish the joke okay
you're trying to like rush me through
[ __ ] and I'm like trying to finish I'm
trying to plug for Merch for Merch man
okay Danny Rowling said great show I'm
not getting hungry yet though yeah yeah
I'm just trying to finish the [ __ ]
show man I got some pizza come okay but
I think I'm gonna do a curry Pizza do
what you want all right where's that
couple where's that raccoon commercial
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
that will never not make me laugh yeah
yeah uh but yeah so this so this guy uh
Mac as they call him I kind of feel like
most of the evidence around this guy
mostly had to do with him happen to be
living in the area like close to the
various crime scenes like oh he moved to
this area and then like you know a week
later like this happened which is a
little fishy I admit but it's not a
crime to like move and also
um the Zodiac letters like corresponding
to major events in his life so that was
that too now Mac actually died in 2014
and in August of 2015 his widow uh
posted online that she had found a box
of his old stuff and she called it the
guilt box
and inside this box was a copy of the
David con book The Code Breakers which
is the same book that experts think that
the Zodiac used as a guide to create his
ciphers now his widow says um yeah macro
like originally read this book in 1980
as far as she knows and he lost his
original copy but he liked it so much
that he bought another one and that was
the one that was in the box
now interestingly though thank you thank
you Bryce thanks Bryce oh they're coming
she asked just shall receive just tuned
in we'll listen to the rest later
Fascinate with the Zodiac case guy was a
creep uh thank you very much Straw Dogs
78 also thanks thank you thank you very
much
yeah we like I said this is the third
time we're doing it but that's okay
because like I said there are some
updates there is some new info and I'm
gonna get into that in like a sec well
this is new info too because I just
found out about this guy like or just 15
minutes these old cases that are kind of
boring to us are [ __ ] have a lot of
[ __ ] crowd interest when we do them
they get the most hits they're not
boring to me you know Tom zodiac we've
done it a bunch of times yeah you know
but for some reason they
they get a good response it's a famous
case it's famous well it's a famous I
mean there's tons of like [ __ ] I mean
if you've ever seen like some of the
Reddit threads about this they're like
[ __ ] millions of words have been
written about this stuff like people
putting up new [ __ ] suspects all the
time right like I said my mom was the
Zodiac you know what I mean it's like
it's ridiculous
um so yeah now none of Max friends uh
significantly uh recalled that he had
any interest in particular in like the
most dangerous game which was like the
Zodiac's favorite story apparently or
the Mercado the Gilbert and Sullivan uh
Operetta
um but he did say that this guy was like
real into comic books and like crime
kind of detective stuff which you know
the Zodiac was as well going by like
some of the references that he made in
some of his letters
uh they said that he was uh licensed to
teach firearms training to prison guards
uh pistols rifle shotguns also his
handwriting was very similar to The
Zodiacs
um they also found it significant that
he was into Freemasonry in the 60s and
70s which maybe had like some kind of
oblique uh thing but yeah so that guy
was like like I said I literally just
what I know why why because some of
those symbols in the ciphers I think
were were Masonic symbols I remember
correctly that's that's what I thought
too that's I think that's why that's
significant they pointed that out yeah
but like I said yeah William McDuff
Andrew that that guy like I literally
just heard about him like 15 20 minutes
like before we started doing the show so
I wrote down like some notes about him
real quick
but the one this main guy that I want to
talk about this is like pretty new
because I had not heard about this
there's I saw one other video about it
on YouTube and then it referred to like
this really really long uh really in
in-depth uh article that was in LA
magazine like just this month it's like
in this month's issue so this is a guy I
literally just heard about like a few
hours ago
so there's a researcher named uh this is
not the suspect this is the researcher
and his name is Jarrett Kovac
and he actually maybe has stumbled on
he might be on to something here he
might be onto something just I'll lay it
out for you and we'll see how you feel
about it
so he's he just completely stumbled upon
this like accidentally which I think is
fascinating
so the guy that we're talking about his
name is Paul Alfred I I'm not sure you
pronounce this last name der doer it's
d-o-e-r-r Doer which to me like looks
German and I kind of feel like that
would be dur because don't they usually
say the OE like you know the e or dare
you know
um uh
Amy the little biker uh bartender her
last name is that
d-o-e-r-o there's across it's just one R
oh okay but she lives across the street
from us Amy Amy door actually it is
dwarf with an F at the end okay that's
completely yeah okay but it's well yeah
now that I think about it but I think
that might be the same name because when
they come through immigration [ __ ]
long time ago they would spell it
phonetically based upon what the
Immigrant said it was see that's why
it's hard to say because I've kind of
seen other names that were kind of
spelled like that and like with an OE
like that and it's usually German
extraction yeah and like usually it's
pronounced it's not pronounced like you
would think it would be pronounced so
I'm not entirely sure so I'm just going
to call him Paul because yes I'm not
gonna like I'm sure I'm pronouncing his
[ __ ] name wrong I don't know if it's
doer if it's dur if it's door if it's I
don't know I'm not sure what it is it's
d-o-e-r-r that's his last name Paul
Alfred it doesn't matter Jenny that's
what I'm saying people aren't Grammar
Nazis well that's what I'm saying it's
just but um well in case people want to
look it up I want to make sure like um
they know how to spell it and everything
like that so this guy we're just going
to call him Paul
he was a guy who lived in the San
Francisco Bay area he died in 2007. now
the way that this author the researcher
uh Kovac stumbled across him
um and this guy as far as I know has
never appeared on any suspect list prior
to this but listen to this [ __ ]
so kobek the researcher he was actually
researching an entirely different book
he was actually writing it about
California in the 1970s but initially he
was going to write about like conspiracy
theories like misinformation like how
conspiracy theories or misinformation
can like kind of morph into like history
into reality right so he was interested
in that but while he was looking into
that he got interested in all of the
speculation surrounding uh the Zodiac
Killer like all of these new suspects
coming out and everything like that so
he wasn't like setting out to write a
book about the Zodiac he was writing
about something else
so he starts looking into the Killer's
case because it was kind of like
relevant to you know what he was writing
about
and
um when he was like looking at all his
zodiac stuff he noticed like all of
these references that were in the
letters that were kind of like referring
to pulp novels like comic books stuff
like that
and he started looking into that kind of
[ __ ] and he started going down this
Rabbit Hole of Bay Area fanzines because
back in the 70s like 60s and 70s
obviously we didn't have the internet so
everybody that was into like nerdy [ __ ]
you know they published their own little
magazines and [ __ ] like that
so he found this one sci-fi fanzine that
was called type beam
and in it he found this letter to the
editor by this guy Paul Dewer whatever
the [ __ ] his name is and he was
criticizing the postal service and said
that you should fight back against the
postal service by addressing your
letters with one cent stamps
and because he had been researching the
Zodiac that kind of like dinged a little
memory he said oh the letter that the
Zodiac sent to Melvin belli
um which was postmarked around the same
time as this letter that was in the
scene
um that letter like to Melvin belli that
the Zodiac sent was sent with six one
cent stamps on it so he's like oh that's
interesting
um you know but it's got to be a
coincidence that's what he thought
now the letter actually had a return
address on it which was a Vallejo PO box
so kobec starts look he's like out of
curiosity he starts looking into this
guy and looking into the address now
this guy
um he said he left behind a huge paper
trail he wrote letters to the editor all
the time he would run classified ads
like Selling Stuff uh he wrote his own
articles for these scenes all that kind
of stuff the first letter article that
he came across was in a scene called
habitalia which you know like I said was
probably like a Tolkien Hobbit kind of
thing hob Italia volume one and it was
this really detailed article about how
um fans of Tolkien used the fictional
runic language for creating codes and
ciphers interestingly he spelled ciphers
with a Y just like zodiac did
habitalia Volume 2 uh the same guy wrote
a letter and he was talking about the
sca the society for Creative anachronism
which you know if you know anything
about them they do medieval cosplay and
interestingly
um he was kind of like well could that
be why zodiac had an Executioner's Hood
because that's like an outfit that you
would dress up for like you know on SCA
interestingly there was a renaissance
fair that took place on the same exact
day as the Lake Berryessa murders which
he thought was kind of interesting too
another one of the zines that this guy
wrote for was called Pioneer and it was
about survivalism
one particular issue had instructions
for making a bomb like an anfo bomb
ammonium nitrate and fertilizer right
easy the same formula that zodiac had
put in his letter and it also had the
same mistake that the Zodiac had made in
the recipe
now the author uh kobek found out that
the formula this particular formula had
first been published in a newsletter by
uh the militant right-wing group The
Minute Men and when he looked into their
minutes from this time period he saw
that this guy Paul Dewar was a member of
that and this group also used a gun
sight symbol bearing a very close
resemblance to the one that the Zodiac
used they would put it in their letters
and things like that
also he said that this guy and the
Zodiac both use like when they drew
diagrams they would draw like an arrow
that had like Little Feather things on
the end like both of them did that like
exactly the same
in one of because remember I said that
this guy like would put would um do like
classified ads like selling stuff in one
of these ads he found
um a reference to a book this guy was
selling which was called The Strange
ways of man this book included a line
about how Headhunters believed their
victims would become their slaves in the
afterlife which was a phrase which was
in a bunch of zodiac letters
now this guy also worked in a Naval
Shipyard in Vallejo at the time of the
killings uh he was the same age the same
height and the same physical appearance
as the descriptions of the zodiac so you
got the naval connection yep okay
uh some of the attacks actually took
place at teen Hangouts like uh make out
spots and stuff like that that doers
daughter Gloria was known to hang out at
also like the Zodiac uh Paul door was
knowledgeable in cryptography and
actually created puzzles for his
daughter every week which she would have
to solve in order to find her allowance
um his daughter Gloria also said that he
taught her self-defense like he enrolled
her in karate classes and tested her
situational awareness by taking her into
a store making her close her eyes and
then asking her how many people were in
the store now Gloria the daughter she
was actually pretty uh skeptical like
when this book first came out she
actually went and read this guy's book
because she was gonna sue him for
defamation like of her dad but when she
read it she was like holy [ __ ] I think
my dad might actually be the Zodiac
because she said that her dad was really
uh abusive
and the more that she read and the more
she kind of like talked to this guy the
more she became she said she didn't
really want to think that but the more
she thought about it like the more it
made sense uh she claimed and there was
a long interview with her too in this
big uh piece that they did in La
magazine she said that her mother Rose
uh would often call him psychotic she
said that her mother and father could
not stand each other Gloria also said
that her dad once threw her up the
stairs with great force and knocked her
out uh that he once hurled her off a
boat because she was complaining and
dragged her alongside the boat with a
rope and that he once tied her hands
together hung her from a tree branch and
whipped the [ __ ] out of her damn uh
Gloria believes that both of her parents
suffered from severe mental illness in
particular paranoid delusions one thing
that she said this is a quote there were
guns everywhere I brought friends over
and it would be do not reach behind that
cushion you have to understand my mother
was as crazy as my father in her own way
according to Gloria the daughter uh her
dad was both a conservationist and a
Libertarian he was really into going to
Renaissance Fairs and he was a member of
a very far-right nativist militia he
worked as a naval documents clerk
according to a co-worker there he was
also a holocaust denier uh in his
leisure time he was really into playing
d and d uh hung out with a bunch of like
fantasy nerds uh but he also would hang
out with Hell's Angels like swapping
guns with them and stuff
he was a big promoter of polygamy uh he
actually told Gloria that he had once
given a lecture on polygamy at a Mensa
meeting because I don't know if he was
really a member of medsa but he said
that he was
um he and also she said if he was a
member of Mensa he'd know how to spell
that's what I'm saying yeah I don't know
if he was because well we'll get into it
later but I think he made up a bunch of
[ __ ] okay he made up a bunch of [ __ ] can
this guy they're talking about can he
spell or is this [ __ ] [ __ ] well I
don't know I don't know okay I but he
did like make up some [ __ ] which we'll
get into in a little bit
um his daughter said that always in his
pockets he always had a notebook a
compass a pen knife a big hunting knife
and two loaded pistols one in each
pocket everywhere he went like he
carried all that stuff now some of the
stuff like I said I feel like he was a
little bit of a fantasist his daughter
said that he told her that he had one
once been invited to a party where J
Edgar Hoover wearing a red sequined
dress greeted him with a kiss on the
lips and thanked him for helping the
Allies win the war
which sounds like a fantasy I don't
think so yeah Hoover was a cross-dresser
but he did he didn't do it in public he
did it in private
yeah so like I said that seems a little
bit yeah uh this guy also said that he
occasionally uh took on wet work I think
he was uh it was just killing people he
was killing people Contract Killer yeah
uh for extra money again probably
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] uh he also told
his daughter that he had once been
invited to a party at this big estate
where wealthy Elites had assembled to
hunt humans nah [ __ ] but he said oh
I tapped out at the last minute because
I couldn't take it like I said that's a
little bit of a fantasist yeah this
seems like the kind of guy that would do
some zodiac [ __ ] uh his he almost sounds
a little too competent but go ahead
yeah Ben said it sounds like a
schizophrenic fantasy yeah he's crazy
but I I have a feeling that the [ __ ]
zodiac wasn't even wasn't even nearly as
competent as this guy or skilled I don't
know it's hard to say it's hard to say I
think the Zodiac was goofball mostly but
we'll see we'll go ahead
uh Gloria actually called him a fascist
but said that he probably suffered from
PTSD
um she also said and remember how I
mentioned like the Gilbert and Sullivan
like the Mikado how a lot of the zodiac
letters had references to the Mikado in
there
um Gloria said that her dad was a big
fan of that particular specific TV
version of the Mikado which actually had
Groucho Marx in it and that he would
play it all the time um so that's kind
of interesting so he was really into
that
uh Gloria also speculated that the first
definitive zodiac murders uh that
occurred just before Christmas of 1968
like the first ones where the the couple
got shot that was right around the same
time
that her dad not only discovered that
she was a copious drug user she was 16
at the time but also had a huge huge
fight with her like she had been out on
a date and she came home and like there
was this massive massive blowout and he
almost killed her like he had like a
psychotic break like he put his hand
around her neck and like lifted her up
off the off the [ __ ] he was basically
accusing her of being like a druggy [ __ ]
even though she wasn't I mean she was a
druggie she didn't admit that but
um yeah so she like they had this huge
but she's like she was so scared uh
because she thought he was gonna kill
her and she fled from the house and
moved in with like a friend of hers like
a teacher and wouldn't see them anymore
because she was like thought he was
gonna kill her also um it's worth noting
like I said and that was right around
the same time she said that was all that
was either the same day or the day
before the first zodiac murder
like that he had this big psychotic
break and almost killed her
um they said it's worth noting too that
the first three zodiac attacks took
place like I said at teen Hangouts like
make out spots and stuff like that
um all of three of those first places
were places that Gloria his daughter
went to uh either on dates
um you know like she had been to the
makeout spots at Lake Herman Road to
kill his daughters pretty much um and
she'd also cut school and gone to Lake
Berryessa before also
um and they were also places where you
could go get drugs if you wanted them
um and there was also the um kobec the
researcher he found this other really
interesting because remember like I said
this guy like wrote tons of like letters
to the editor he found one that this guy
had written and it was um it was from
November 1st 1974 and it was this
neo-pagan journal called Green Egg now
in the previous edition of this uh the
founder of the publication said um he
was talking about oh my four-year-old
daughter like I left her with these
people and they intentionally dosed her
with LSD like what should I do about
that and so this guy was responding to
that and in the letter he wrote um he
said that he offered to uh I suggest
various physical procedures you could
carry out it might be better if you
don't print this part of my letter I was
in a vaguely similar situation some
years ago and there are fewer people
here because of it now that's what he
said and then he said that he didn't
want like he didn't want that part
printed but that publication like they
printed what you wrote like whether they
didn't like take Parts out so he
apparently did not want that printed he
just wanted that personal late toward
that guy but that would seem to imply
you know it just implies something
um so they're kind of operating under
the assumption that this if this guy was
the Zodiac that maybe he was he couldn't
kill her because that was his daughter
but he was maybe punishing other young
people that he thought were like on the
same path as her because she was like a
druggie and he thought she was a hoe and
all this other kind of [ __ ]
um so it could be that and like I said
it did seem like
the worst of the crimes like I don't
know if he committed the earlier [ __ ] or
whatever but like the 1968 like the
first canonical one happened right
around the same time that there was this
big huge [ __ ] Blowout at home and she
left home you know what I mean like when
she was 16. he sounds like a good
candidate on the surface but the more I
think about it I don't think I don't
think the dude I don't think the Zodiac
was a guy like that
this guy was just the dude you're
talking about is a [ __ ] intense dude
real explosive
[ __ ] uh tamper uh fan assist uh but
reads a lot of books probably writes a
lot of stuff I'd like to see what his
writing was like yeah you could fake
being a dummy misspelling things on
purpose
but the the personality doesn't feel the
same to me
this guy is trying to be basically kind
of like a [ __ ] James Bond type dude
um he's got already got a family he's
got daughters and stuff it's just
I think the dude that did it was more
kind of like Berkowitz uh kind of a
a bigger dude but kind of dumpy uh
probably net probably Like a Virgin uh
[ __ ] was uh
kind of displaced anger towards uh
sexual activity not much older than the
victims probably
um underachiever badly educated didn't
have much money I don't think
uh may have had something to do with
shipyards and or at least was a wannabe
what you know she's trying to open she's
trying to get in the cabin trying to get
in the cabinet
um he's
he's I think he's got I'm seeing him
more as a guy like Berkowitz like much
more of an underachiever than this guy
you know I think he was a couple notches
below this dude in terms of
being able to function if you ask me I
think a lot of some say that you know it
was described as having a good haircut
and [ __ ]
um you know kind of being [ __ ] and span
in terms of the [ __ ] his grooming
they don't know if that was the
the Zodiac or not but maybe
and so they say well because of that you
know he may have been had a military
background but a lot of guys kind of
looked that way in that era
and
there's a lot of these kind of guys want
to be things that they're not so they
kind of adapt adopt the mannerisms and
kind of like The Superficial
philosophies of
cops or soldiers or something like that
you know so they kind of end up looking
like that or wanting to look like that
so I don't know
yeah this the dude that she's talking
about this new suspect that's a nut you
know
but I don't I don't think I don't think
he's a zodiac I mean I haven't read the
book there might be like some other
stuff in there but I mean it sounded
plausible it sounded like more plausible
than some of the other stuff that they
because at least they had like all these
connections with various things that
were in the letters you know what I mean
like all his interests and stuff I'm
thinking he's more of a guy along the
lines of Berkowitz and like like if you
were to crossbreed Berkowitz and BTK and
Charles Raider then maybe you'd have
something like that or Dennis ready
excuse me she was Charles Raider I don't
know I thought there might have been a
Charles Raider but he's kind of like I
think
and I think maybe he would have been
a little bit below Dennis Raider in
terms of [ __ ]
boogie boogie we got into the damn
cabinet and then left
so that it wasn't in there okay now
she's laying down going yeah I went in
there it's [ __ ] funny let's see what
the uh comments are and I just got a
feeling it's got a feeling about it that
dude sound I don't think that's him
I think it's of a guy that's a lot less
organized than that a guy who can't
really manage his life too well
um
I think he's single I don't think he's a
a married guy
and I definitely don't think he has any
kids I think he's a single loser kind of
like [ __ ] Berkowitz
is it crossbreed I didn't want that
visual yeah I know Rebecca crossbreeding
those two dudes would be funny
all right
Ben says many Geniuses can't spell and
he spelled the [ __ ] with one L that's
funny
okay
Michael's asked me the question he says
Tom you've lived in a few places I'm
from California I keep hearing my whole
life the Florida people are weird have
you guys noticed this
no
depends on how you Define weird
Florida people aren't weird California
I'm from California too or I [ __ ] you
know I was actually born in California
and left in 81. down Carson around
Carson area
now Californians are far weirder than
[ __ ] floor Indians Florida is a
couple different regions you got the
Panhandle you got Central Florida and
South Florida it's it's like it's kind
of like uh uh it's kind of like Central
America and a lot of it
well the thing about Florida is like
yeah there's no kind of one Florida
person because most people that live
here are from someplace else yeah
there's been a lot of migration into the
state over the years so Florida used to
be empty uh until the air conditioning
came out you
the average person really couldn't
survive in Florida without air
conditioning so it opened up migration
um
but it's not that much hotter than
Mississippi or or Louisiana or
Alabama and those are sparsely
sparsely populated states too because
it's the heat the heat and humidity
although today it was beautiful yeah it
got nice today I mean today I don't
think it got above 65 degrees and I was
like freaking out it doesn't usually get
this cool as early in the year it's 55
degrees right now and I am loving it
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome in general
Florida's Party Town
it's got good clubs
uh
got
cute women uh just of all different
kinds there's a bunch of different
scenes there's cute people everywhere
yeah but it's well no no there's not no
lie
either is what are you talking about
there are reasons there are regions of
Mississippi there aren't any really cute
people there yeah but that's because
there's only like an Appalachian there's
only four people and they're all related
to one another you can come to
Appalachian but no one would ever go
there yeah so you'd find nothing but
people about 70 IQ with half nobody
would go there unless you were like
going somewhere else and like your car
broke down and then yeah
and badly inbred and [ __ ]
um so but it's uh
Florida's nice I've been all over a
[ __ ] uh I love Florida Jenny's only
really only lived here so she doesn't
really have anything to compare I mean I
lived in the UK too yeah that's true UK
but uh
right now
I like the South you know and I've lived
up in the north of the uh [ __ ] up in
Boston and New England area which that
was good too it's just man it's got its
own [ __ ] problems and the culture is
not really I didn't really like the
culture that much
um
I I can I can really at this time at
this stage in life I can really only
live in the south or or I could go back
to Brazil too I lived in Brazil [ __ ]
I like Brazil but Brazil's my friends
that I grew up with in Brazil [ __ ]
say the Brazil is [ __ ] horrible right
now it's like
worse than Colombia back in the 80s you
know it's extremely violent uh because
it's it's an anarcho tyranny basically
where it's just nothing functions it's a
totally dysfunctional and it's been that
way for [ __ ] decades so it's not like
a new thing it's when I lived there
[ __ ] Brazil was not dysfunctional you
know nothing really worked
you know cops will pull you over and
then try to sell you a gun
or drugs you know that kind of [ __ ] but
um
yeah I don't know no Florida's [ __ ]
great I like Florida
Ben says uh zodiac being military was
based uh number one on his boot prints
being from boots only available from PX
stores and being able to sew which was a
Navy requirement yeah that's uh mostly
where that came from yeah yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't put much into it
though well I don't you know I don't
really know yeah you
military gear can [ __ ] get handed
down and through friends and you can get
guys who are [ __ ] military groupies
and worshipers and wannabes and [ __ ]
can get their hands on anything military
they know what it what it was that we
were buying and or being issued and blah
blah blah blah another thing is is that
when I was in service if you were using
[ __ ] standard issue GI [ __ ]
other than the BDU uniforms and the
k-pots and the body armor and the
[ __ ] the guns and [ __ ] all the other
[ __ ] that we had was [ __ ] [ __ ] we
bought from the U.S cab it was all which
is a store
we carried more than half of the [ __ ] I
[ __ ] carried or used was after market
aftermarket stuff
the military stuff wasn't as good as the
[ __ ] that you could buy like Matterhorn
boots and things you know what I mean
they were [ __ ] much better than GI
issue boots
um just
camo paint was aftermarket was better
just because you spend a little bit more
then you're gonna get more you know
[ __ ]
and nobody carried a [ __ ] GI issue
flashlight a little bent flashlight [ __ ]
we you carried many maglites
it was much better
all right so uh where was I okay so um
yeah so basically I was almost done yeah
uh so kobec said that after he gathered
all this information like turned into a
book he actually did turn all the
information over to uh the San Francisco
Police Department uh they have so far
not commented on the allegations now
there have been some kind of like high
profile researchers into the case
including uh Paul Haynes who actually
was one of the co-writers of
um I'll be gone in the dark which was
about the Golden State killer
um he seems to think that Kovac is like
I said on to something and he's just
kind of like yeah I think this might be
the guy but he said the problem is that
you know now everybody and their mom
like you know is releasing a new zodiac
suspect every week so it's like probably
this book should have come out like 20
years ago and then people would have
been impressed but now people are just
kind of like oh here we go again like
here's another one so it's it's more
like like I said it's more like because
the [ __ ] uh field has become so
crowded but uh a lot of other kind of
like prominent researchers like the guy
Tom void that runs uh the website and
one of the guys that figured out the um
z340 Cipher
um are not really all that impressed by
it and I should say too that Robert
graysmith the guy that read the book
doesn't even want to know like he won't
even read the book which seems a little
[ __ ] to me but whatever he's still I
guess he's still riding the Arthur Lee
Allen horse even though I'm pretty sure
that Arthur Lee Allen didn't do it but
like I said I'm not saying that this I
mean this is very very new like I just
read this article like today it just
came out in this month's uh issue
of La magazine and I don't know how long
the book's been out but apparently like
not that long because there's only been
a couple reviews of it but I don't know
it just sounded interesting to me
there's a lot of coincidences
particularly about like little
little things that were referred to in
the letters that I think were like kind
of interesting and there was like a lot
of coincidence in there so like I said I
don't know if this is the guy it's got
it but like I said it has to be somebody
it has to be somebody somebody did that
[ __ ] and one of these days we'll figure
out who it is and I hope it happens in
my lifetime but I don't know if it's
this guy but we'll see
um let's see
Michael says I just watched Jarhead hey
Tom were you that were you there in 1991
where what
where was I and where in 1991. I don't
know what he's talking about what what's
the matter yeah
I can't do brushing she can watch me go
down here she's in the brush position
yeah yeah I can't brush right now she's
like please please come brush me oh well
if we end the show I'll come over I'll
brush you in a minute is she mad oh
she's mad yeah she's coming you know she
told me I was in the service yeah I
thought that's between 99 No 19 I went
September 24 1990 to September 24 94.
and then I did Reserve time and contract
time
StarTalk 78 said if you define weird as
people who can't drive then yeah Florida
has a lot of weird people
survived Florida without a car there's
no public transport no I mean but people
do drive like [ __ ] down here they're
South American that's for sure I don't
they're not all yes you see a
[ __ ] like crazy I grew up in
Brazil you see a [ __ ] driving
like [ __ ] crazy that's a Brazilian
Brazilians all have [ __ ] they all
think they're Nelson PK who [ __ ]
who's a [ __ ] Brazilian [ __ ] race
car driver you should see Brazilian in
South and Central American traffic it's
a [ __ ] race all right and they try to
get in front of each other even though
there's a traffic jam in front of there
it's just part of their culture and a
lot of them [ __ ] have [ __ ]
um a toxoplasmosis [ __ ] you
know what I mean which makes them real
Risk Takers and [ __ ] hoes they're
[ __ ] sexually exploited [ __ ]
just look up toxoplasmosis Brazil has
the highest incident of toxoplasmosis it
makes you a [ __ ] aggressive driver
and a sexy [ __ ] that can't keep
your dick out of other women that's what
that's what that's what other people's
women [ __ ] they come here and they do
great they get everybody's Wives
pregnant Brazilian dudes yeah especially
in the horse business they took over the
[ __ ] horse industry I know I was in
it
okay they're getting all the clients
while I was pregnant and the daughter is
pregnant
Danny Rowling asks I think it's gone now
but Danny Rowling asked if uh any women
were ever put forward as Zodiac Killer
no because
um some of the victims survived and they
clearly described him as like a dumpy
white guy yeah like a 200 pound white
guy yeah I'm telling you he's a wannabe
he's like a BTK mixed with Berkowitz
he's like that
Ben said the thing you get from cats
toxoplasmosis yeah and I think I got a
[ __ ] weird feeling man I just do I
got this weird feeling that the uh you
know my psychic [ __ ] feelings okay uh
even I'm trans psycho I can [ __ ] feel
it the [ __ ]
the Zodiac was a virgin
I think
he's stabbing them women and focusing on
them with a knife yeah he does seem like
he does kind of sound like an insult he
can't get the dick in him so he puts the
[ __ ] blade in him that's what he's
doing it's like thrusting okay well like
I said I kind of feel like a lot of even
if they're not technically virgins
because I know a lot of them aren't like
so like I said like BTK like he was
married yeah and he had kids yeah but um
I mean the mindset is kind of similar
though yeah it's kind of similar but I
think he's more like Berkowitz and I
wouldn't surprise me if Berkowitz was a
[ __ ]
virgin or a dude that could only had to
pay to get laid something like that
I don't think yeah maybe Rick Woodson
had a way with women you know but
neither the BTK he got married they got
women out there that'll marry anybody
especially back in those days
what are your standards well that's the
thing it's like especially back then if
you're a woman you're just like well you
need a man he's around right yeah right
and he doesn't seem too terrible right
so you just got to put up with the [ __ ]
yeah you know what I mean
yeah zodiac was a white man yeah he's
definitely he was definitely like a
dumpy white dude yeah like several
people saw him
um all right so I guess we'll wrap it up
see three and a half hours and I covered
everything that I and we covered the
whole entire case again yeah I think we
did good he's naming off all the all the
people that were from Florida and [ __ ]
he matches Jim Morrison yeah I think Jim
Morrison might have been from Florida
but I think I thought he was from
Gainesville right I think so but I think
he he was more of a creation of
California
um but you also forget [ __ ] Marilyn
mats is from here a lot of people from
here all them damn porn stars are from
here or live here you look at that porn
and all that [ __ ] backgrounds and in
in the pools and the [ __ ] palm trees
and all those [ __ ] hot big titty porn
star that's Florida and some of them we
know
few of them but
it's a big industry here it's just not
in California like it was it's all over
here
Disney Corp probably and probably behind
a lot of it
Rebecca says thank you for the hard work
yes great show you're very welcome yeah
I had a good time doing this but I mean
like we've covered it before but there's
always like new stuff to talk about so
yeah hopefully it wasn't like too boring
for everybody going over the same stuff
again but we didn't know like if
different people were here and there was
like new [ __ ] and I actually was really
interested in like this new guy even if
he's not that guy like it's interesting
I don't know just like the whole article
it was interesting to me like how it
came in and like I said it's got to be
somebody So eventually they'll find out
who the [ __ ] is and I'm just
curious I'm sure he's dead by now but
if he's not he's like [ __ ] 90 years
old yeah
um but yeah all right so are we gonna
wrap it up and you're gonna go make some
pizza yeah all right so thank you
everybody for dropping by thank you for
your super chats uh we love you guys we
love hanging out with you every
Wednesday evening we'll be back again
Friday night for our Sidetrack show
maybe we'll go get some weird booze like
tomorrow or Friday and try to do like a
taste test like we were gonna do like
for every show and then we just kind of
forgot about it but we'll maybe do it
again like this time so we'll see you
guys again on Friday evening so have a
good rest of your evening have a good
day tomorrow and we'll see you guys
again on Friday evening good night